[Musique]
alors t'as vu ce qui se passe à tous au
nom de quoi tu parles de quoi la radio
ou à la télé les journaux tout le monde
en face à le truc mais oui ce matin je
fais le haut précis m'attends à tout
moment pas alors c'est foutu c'est que
j'ai eu trois candidats dans l'aventuré
à parler aussi bien si l'on parle quand
il eut aussi lui l'emportent ça veut
dire que tout le monde en parle
l'usm du soir
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez titoff le voici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
top bon alors si l'on ma fille n'est pas
là et inutile de vous dire c'est qu'il a
bougé pendant le jingle ah ouais j'ai vu
j'ai vu ça il a bougé pendant le jingle
de rouquine est à l'amande voilà ce que
je veux dire aux étapes comme c'est la
première fois vous êtes un petit peu
étudiants en tout le monde en parle
donc si besoin de poser des questions de
vous renseigner sur ce qui se passe
sedran n'hésitez pas à demander non mais
ça va on m'a dit de pas bouger pendant
le jingle ça c'est très important
jusque là ça va et moi j'ai répété j'ai
pas bougé pendant les jingles et pendant
le jingle et alors ça vous y arriver
maintenant et je me suis entraîné bon
ben ça va très bien
[Applaudissements]
miso brecko ça bastonne ailleurs ça
aussi mais faut pas bouger
on attendait maintenant à quoi on va
faire tu vas voir si vous avez répété ça
aussi fait
et attention tu te remercie mise à
partie quand je recevrai ce soir à free
un accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est du bon
gunter sachs
mongi avis
à l'allemagne
ok
jean-jacques le garrec
jean jacques schuhl
[Applaudissements]
et
michael est toujours un c'est qu'avec ce
genre là malheureusement est ce qu'on
écoute parti pour changer se sortir ici
on parle de cul
et toi
on n'a jamais rien n'arrête la cenap
tueur là on arrête là c'est la fureur là
beaucoup david il ya du boulot voilà
alors j'ai vu dire avant de commencer
parce que c'est comme la chose la plus
importante de la semaine j'ai reçu une
petite carte de madame de fontenay et
les regarde mais sa faute au regard
jumbo garçon regarde way geneviève elle
met sa photo est alors je ne viens je me
dis bravo cher thierry pour votre set
dans bien méritée merci geneviève c'est
pas le plus important le plus important
est à venir
j'étais près de bordeaux pour l'élection
de miss aquitaine avec sonia et sa suite
peut-être pourriez-vous venir au sofitel
et faire partie du jury mais oui
geneviève
bien sûr j'aime bien quand tu veux je
[Applaudissements]
sache la garde non voilà qui voulaient
venir faire partie du jury clippers
aimerait bien si j'aimerais c'est bien
les jurys des mille-pattes irritation de
voir mes enfants descendent le chapeau
alors elle a des cheveux j'ai croisés
dans des dans le sol
c'est juste le
j'ai fait si je regardais pas les
cheveux partie par exemple ou encore
tiken jah blachas pas le seul bien alors
vous savez vous avez révisé vous avez
appris j'imagine les répéter vous savez
dans cette émission pas bougé puis vous
savez et titoff qui a une tradition dans
cette émission c'est une tradition
d'ailleurs que beaucoup d'autres chaînes
de télévision nous envient à commencer
par france 3 c'est de montrer les
meilleurs moments de la semaine
précédente
voilà ma naissance et voici henri
salvador
m
vous changeriez quoi si vous aviez une
baguette magique
beh web a voulu dire tous vos muscles un
bar à je ne sais pas non je n'irai pas
jusque là mais c'est vrai qu'on a j'ai
réussi par exemple j'avais déjà est ce
que vous êtes géronto ah oui par rapport
à non par rapport à tout le monde comme
moi pour avoir moi aussi c'est quand on
aime les gens plus âgés visage et
comment vous avez vous présente plus
pourquoi vous avez quel âge j'ai bientôt
ça fait trente huit combinés dans le
baba et ça va continuer jusqu'à ce qu'on
la met en circulation dans 12 ou 14 14 -
pardon est-ce que vous suivez aurait dit
j'ai un peu décroché la chasse à la
bombe et c'est décidément
ol et vous me dites en arrivant thierry
je veux plus voir de danseurs je vais me
changer les idées je me changeais la
tête etc
mais là c'est trop je vous présente en
quelqu'un qui vous change la tête
alors vous êtes né en 49 mais on sait on
sait pas grand chose sur vous et oui et
ça nous intéresse pas non plus
quelle est votre première pensée quand
vous trouvez à un homme séduisant change
et 33 vous méfier de vous même en
rompant son mari et tu vas le voir
traverser matin je suis co q - est-ce
que vous croyez à l'efficacité des
crèmes antirides certaine c'est bien des
mains si vraiment ça vous va très bien
mais c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
parler aux femmes qu'est ce que le
groupe
c'est une façon de dire vous êtes jolie
c'est sa façon à lui de faire des
compliments salon son chien
je suis un peu balourd mais bon quelle
histoire d'amour
et sur les yeux vous portez way et les
lentilles spéciales qui valent 55000
font la paire quel frimeur alors il y a
personne au fond de l'eau
ap
pour votre préparation pas de tabac pas
d'alcool pas de filles ouais pendant la
descente et l'or a monté oui et les
oreilles bon alors j'ai essayé mais je
me vois c'était le best-of de la semaine
dernière vous n'êtes pas sur france 3
vous êtes bien sur france 2 l'émission
s'appelle tout le monde en parle bien
alors tu t'offres
et c'est un bonheur un bonheur surtout
que là en plus c'est votre promo avoue
titoff donc c'est important cette
demande
alors on va faire ça très sérieusement
bien sûr ce moment la promo la promo
c'est sérieux la promo laurent baffie
dit que je suis le mec le plus nul en
promo qu'il ait jamais rencontrée je
suis très fier de vous c'est vrai sur
les maladies et plusieurs fois vous en
foutez puisque votre spectacle marche
oui c'est plat est alors s'est plaint la
semaine et le week-end ya du monde où il
ya du monde la semaine et c'est un week
end et fois le théâtre en laisse ouvert
le théâtre il ya du monde dédiée ou et
titoff ça marche super bien revenir sur
palais des glaces l'année dernière
c'était au trévise donc il faut dire aux
gens j'ai encore des gens qui vont très
vite il paraît ah oui ouais donc il faut
leur dire c'est au palais des glaces ben
oui je suis au palais des glaces
tu as vu comme je suis mauvais ça veut
dire maintenant je suis au palais des
glaces à 20h30
du mardi au samedi et c'est super c'est
perdre et on se marre du début à la fin
ça je vous le dis alors voilà si vous y
allez si vous vous marrez pas envoyer
moi des emails je vais lire à l'antenne
ça m'étonnerait qu'elle ait beaucoup ok
ça se rembourse pas
[Applaudissements]
pour toujours chez moi dans sa
tranquille en plein après midi vous
achetez chez moi votre and kill où
j'étais là je me dis bienvenue le coup
et n'a portail monde doit on jeter bien
au stadium plein à un peu après midi
concédés coup je reçois une lettre comme
ça en plein après midi mais quelle chez
sur le monde devient fou
on est calme toi tu t'enflammes antoine
en plein après midi et en fait c'était
c'est une invitation pour une soirée
mondaine et ma foi ça va être bien venir
bon moi je savais pas trop comment
m'habiller alors ce que j'ai fait j'ai
téléphoné une copine à moi qui ai un peu
l'habitude d'être tout de suite elle m'a
dit ah oui tu fais une soirée mondaine
la grande mode en ce moment des semis
dieu sait mettre des baskets avec un
constat merci beaucoup à manger chercher
de l'après midi comme un fou des
costards des costards bon j'ai pas
trouvé de costa lorsque j'ai fait moi je
la nature mais nous aimons cassé
non ce qui marche bien que tu fais avec
son livre on sait les médicaments elle
et les somnifères
le plus efficace et les somnifères un
suppositoire c'est les plus efficaces si
c'est trop fort c'est trop rapide
moi j'ai essayé une fois je ne serais
rien de même hâte et j'ai même corde au
cou moi j'ai un truc surtout pourront
jamais être stressé j'ai une règle d'or
c'est ne jamais remettre les chansons
datent de mai juin à nu le carré ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] tu au palais des glaces
tous les soirs à 20h30 voilà bon alors
j'ai reçu beaucoup du mail pour se dire
le combat de laurent baffie
c'est vrai que ça commence la révolution
commence on veut pouvoir bouger pendant
le jingle
la révolution est en marche beaucoup
beaucoup du mail
patrick chapelière may cry moi je me
suis grattée les couilles pendant le
dîner gala franchement organes c'est
désolant et paul sinclair dit lui je ne
bouge que pendant le jingle donc c'est
bien pour t'emmerder art dix ans
d'études et voilà
et alors il ya richard gaudin lui
l'enregistrer mission parce qu'il peux
pas la regarder de samedi soir et il dit
est ce que quand on a enregistré
l'émission et crous l'art passe alors un
document est ce qu'on ne va bull voulu
ou pas bougé non on bouge pas même si on
a enregistré l'émission bouge pas par le
jingle enfin merde bon alors il ya
beaucoup de mails aussi pour aurélie
dupont
aurélie dupont qui a beaucoup séduit nos
amis téléspectateurs
cette étoile est un vrai cadeau du ciel
j'ai compris en l'envoyant que j'étais
pas amoureux de ma copine
comment il s'appelle bah il s'appelle
vincent est alors sa copine s'appelle
stéphanie mais voilà de stéphanie t'en
fais pas une maîtrise un peu pour que je
te le dise quoi profites-en ça marche
pas avec lui voilà obligé de régler tout
à waimes moi j'ai un boulot de chien moi
je fais un courrier du coeur j'aurais le
plein de problèmes comme ça c'est
terrible
et alors évidemment il ya tous ceux qui
fantasment sur la connaissance parfaite
qu'aurélie dupont a de son corps ça
fascine beaucoup de gens voient là et là
alors la personne qu'on va accueillir
maintenant on va vivre à beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup du mail la semaine
prochaine les images n'ont pas fini d
arrivée
voici la bombe atomique voient si
adriana karembeu
bah
m
[Applaudissements]
adriana karembeu la demande de vous
arrêter vous embêter adriana karembeu la
plus belle chose qui nous a été envoyé
par les pays de l'est
si vous êtes magnifique la plus belle
chose qui est venu de l'est depuis
toujours alors vous êtes de plus en plus
jolie
je suis toujours gentil avec vous je le
trouve de plus en plus joli en plus
vraiment alors il ya un problème c'est
que moi quand je travaille chez moi
comme ça j'ai lci allumée toute la
journée sans le son c'est juste pour
avoir l'heure et est alors toute la
journée il ya un spot qui parce que les
cuadrillas karembeu et quand on voit le
spot on dit comment il fait pour bosser
hardy s'emmerde matin
[Musique]
les gestes qui sauvent avec la croix
rouge c'est un mannequin qui voulait ça
prendra
si adriana n'est pas là c'est robert qui
s'en chargera dans le stock de la
croix-rouge sensibilisation du grand
public bien alors donc c'était un spot
pour la croix rouge pour les gestes qui
sauvent pour apprendre aux gens les
gestes qui sauvent
est ce votre participation je dis tout
de suite et bénévoles c'est à dire que
vous avez accepté de faire tout ça sans
gagner d'argent c'est très beau hélas
alors là vraiment de cette fois la
france vous aime encore plus voilà parce
que l'on peut dire c'est vrai là
maintenant vraiment ça y est ce qui veut
dire c'est qu'en france il ya seulement
32 % des gens qui sont formés aux
premiers secours
alors qu'en angleterre ils sont 44
années de mainz étonnera personne ils
ont de réformer les allemands au premier
et gour ils sont 80% être formés aux
premiers secours nous on est que voilà
alors s'il y avait 20 % de la population
française qui étaient formés aux
premiers secours
on sauverait dix mille vies par an les
premiers se qualifieront barba non parce
que les gens ce qui se passe dit offre
un espace ce qui se passe c'est que les
gens meurent avant l'arrivée des
premiers secours mais je dis ça en
marron mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
vers à travers patrick dupond que notre
invité ce soir qu'il se retrouve un jour
sur l'autoroute de normandie en morceaux
ans d'écart quoi c'est un grand écart et
là je suis coincé à personne et pourtant
ce sont des gestes simples qui peuvent
sauver d'ailleurs pitof oui je voulais
vous avez rocher la wii
[Applaudissements]
nous allons générer la wii et adriana
rihanna va vous apprendre à nous
apprendre à tous les gestes qui se
faisait beaucoup de chance titoff parce
que vous avez d'habitude c'est robert
l'habitude c'est robert c'est un
mannequin je te donne un petit chewing
gum
moi je vois c'est bien mais vous sa
bouche c'est on le bouge alors c'est un
puzzle
allongez-vous jeu mais comment fait du
match c'est la plage comme ça arrive
vous êtes intéressé alors je dois fait
de laisser inconscient
ah oui complètement alors d'abord
légales
la place est mort je suis un peu fatigué
a pas danger on va s'occuper de la
victime
alors d'abord on va regarder s'il
respire on va basculer la tête en
arrière
combien on va écouter s'il respire
et c'est sérieux c'est pour sauver nos
vies
normalement avec at on écoute si elle
respire en lega petit sa poitrine ça
bouge mais il respire très bien ils
respirent un peu vite même je pense oui
car si on respire bien voilà manager ont
fait 1100 position cela côté position de
sécurité c'est comment la pression je ne
vais pas vous montrer parce que il va
tomber mais vas-y tu peux me c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je
m'intéresse aux gestes qui sauvent
mais toi mais toi sur le côté tu
t'offres montréjeau relate la possession
survivre voilà voilà
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
les accords actuels
ah non non et une céramiste bel et bien
oui
les années n'ont jamais été à la tête
parce que c'est important on respire pas
on fait bouche à bouche et à la masse hk
bien oui mais un massage cardiaque c'est
comment trouvez vous la bouche aussi
prévoit que vous respirez déjà alors on
n'a pas besoin faire ok sinon on fait
deux fois oui
aïcha bouche après on trouve les sternes
ou elena et moitié en fait qu à la
moitié du sternum on fait ça pour faire
redémarrer le coeur c'est que l'on
répète 1 5 fois par minute après
examinations si elle ne respire pas on
appelle ça mouline bien sûr parce qu'un
à bergerac live au bar des amis ont
besoin
bravo dit
bien essayé tous bien compris tu vas tu
allongez-vous sur le c'était ça marche
que dans un sens c'est une très bonne
idée de la part de la croix-rouge de
vous avoir choisi lasker en fait la
croix-rouge voulait s'adresser à un
public jeune et pas de là d'une manière
qui s'enlise ouais c'est pourquoi ils
ont choisi c'est une très bonne idée
d'un seul coup tout le monde s'intéresse
à cette fois ça y est af corse même
titoff bien alors justement au sujet des
gestes qui sauvent et des accidents de
la route j'aurais juste lire un email
peut-être un peu moins gai que les
autres c'est pour dire à philippe que
j'ai bien su ton message pour anne flore
voilà si une fille en a plein comme ça
c'est comme franska dernier qui s'est
pris un coup de couteau
l'autre jour à côté d' il ya plein de
gens comme ça qui disparaissent sans
raison là c'est un mec avait un peu trop
bu sont rentrés à s'en prendre à
l'ayroule à 30 et anne flore qui n'avait
rien demandé à personne est morte voilà
donc j'espère que grâce à vous et grâce
à ce genre d'initiative on arrivera
calmés un peu c'est hécatombe de la
route en france
à
alors on va rester dans les gestes qui
sauvent on va vous faire une interview
j'ai remarqué pourparlers très très bien
le français maintenant alors l'interview
alerte aux roses
vous aurez peut-être besoin que vous
avez une traductrice de la geste qui
sauve
on ne bouge pas pendant le single
[Musique]
et voilà tu n'as pas bouger tant que
vous n'avez pas bougé par un jean
jacques chinon et adriana n'a pas bougé
non plus bravo christophe ayad
vous avez une fade là la première arrive
à faire à réussir un truc aussi dur
vraiment c'est bien on va vous avez
regretté bien alors là l'interview
alerte aux roses
si vous comprenez en français vous
répondre en français sinon vous répondez
en anglais elle est notre ami
traductrice qui est là je crois bien sûr
bien ce que tu es là toujours tout à
fait je le vois tu es prêt tu t'appelles
comment bill d'un rang belinda une
chanson peu fort soit bel et bien alors
qu'elle est la première pensée que vous
avez adriana karembeu quand vous vous
trouvez en face d'un homme séduisant
je pense à moi maintenant je ne pense
plus à lens à l'époque dans le temps
c'est adriana je vais tout de suite
c'est pas l'interview mensonge vous
pouvez répondre la vérité là quel est
pour vous et adriana le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte de besplas de baisse
presque partout partout
[Applaudissements]
si c'est la bonne personne
tous les lieux la bonne réponse bonne
réponse si c'est la bonne personne tous
les lieux sont bons c'est parfait quel
est l'endroit adriana karembeu vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour une space
dante et gâvres l'histoire je pense que
je ne maîtrise pas ce à cause de la
pesanteur
oui c'est à faire l'amour dans la pub ça
va être difficile déjà faut se couvrir
les grilles connu déjà pour s'embrasser
avec le vous préférez draguer ou faire
draguer je préfère franchement comme mag
non enfin on se renseigne loin vous
préférez vous faire préférer larguer les
mecs vous faire larguer évidemment je
préfère être celle qui part j'aime
beaucoup plus gratifiant si que ça va
bêler iba un vélib est un bel hymne à la
vie
elle est bien belinda bien vous préféré
embrasser ou vous faire embrasser elle
peut chaque ticket je préfère un
principe caresser ou vous faire caresser
les deux copines catherine me dit en
régie que vous n'arrêtez pas de regarder
si je fais un portois
non
non mais c'est pas vrai et nous allons
voir se former à la main et auxerre le
micro et était tombé le micro
l'optimisme prudent j'ai regardé j'ai
lesquelles il s'est remis en place
et si on refait donc ralentissant on
revient en arrière vous verrez que le
micro d'adriana était tombé comme ça à
l'envié mais on va pas l'entendre je les
missions en moi adriana karembeu
j'avais même pas remarqué non
est-ce que vous conservez aggravée dans
la mode
adriana est ce que vous pensez à ce que
vous conservez un fantasmes inavouables
vas-y belinda traduit celle où j'aurai
beaucoup de fantasmes
il ya encore des fantasmes je vais pas
réaliser qu'ils sont encore dans votre
tête seulement oui monsieur guy roux qui
est déchets hard et je le vois faire des
devis ou via des outils dits pourquoi je
rentre pas sur le placer attendu
on attend 5 minutes bien alors
maintenant des gens qui m'a qui
m'envoient des questions comme ça par
imen un dénommé tristan poirier alors il
dit vous demander si vous préférez vous
demandez aux gens ciel officiel préfère
un homme infidèle qui fait bien l'amour
à un fidèle qui fait mal d'amour
alors il dit au moyen âge comme quoi
c'est vraiment une émission culturelle
c'est incroyable au moins il y avait les
poètes des poètes du moyen-âge il jouer
à des débats amoureux qui s'appelait les
jeux partie et alors ils avaient des
questions comme ça finalement n'a rien
inventé au moyen-âge j'avais déjà ça par
exemple lors je posais c'est vraiment
une question du moyen âge ça c'est
historique en ces tristes [ __ ] ils
habitent dans le 16e et très sérieux et
ou alors est-ce que vous préférez
posséder si vous deviez posséder la
moitié d'un homme vous préféreriez avoir
le haut ou le bas difficile mais c'est
un truc mais là je pense que si oui ou
non parce qu'il y avait une solution ou
alors tu passer pour quelqu'un de
romantique où tu passer pour une super
chaude
alors
conscient celle-là elle public et un
question du moyen âge faut-il mieux
croire que votre mec vous trompe sans
être sûrs ou être sûr qu'il vous a
trompé mais le fera plus est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux croire que votre mec vous
trompe sans être sûrs ou être sur qui
vous a trompé mais qui ne fera plus la
belle linda elle rame je suis sûr que la
thur à main mais je ne veux pas que je
sois d'accord bref vous préférez quoi un
question à une autre femme dans sa vie
christian après il a une autre femme
dans sa vie s'il tient jeu il a une
femme dans sa vie
il vous reçoit les deux le même soir sur
vous et son hôte et sa maîtresse il vous
reçoit les deux même sorti un jeu est un
jeu est ce qu'il vaut mieux arriver
deuxième lorsque l'autre femme sort
satisfaites ou sortir satisfaite quand
l'autre arrive on peut faire tomber le
ferai si je préfère un très bon ami de
faire sortir satisfaite quand l'autre
arrive d'accord d'accord comme à la
guerre
qu'est ce que je puis après je m'en
moque d'accord bon par contre si ces
demoiselles
moi j'étais conscient des triploïdes et
à revenir aussi les doigts en même temps
parce que je ferais si j'étais question
mais bon c'est pas moi yen-hsun et au
moyen-âge industrie la moyenne et voilà
[Applaudissements]
bien j'accueille maintenant sans plus
attendre quelqu'un qui est très très
chaud très chaud en coulisses c'est guy
roux
dire bonsoir bonsoir vous connaissez
adriana karembeu je la connais de vue
bien sûr maintenant vous êtes tradition
mais je connais christian depuis très
longtemps depuis les juniors de nantes
heynckes j'essayais de christian avant
elle a été difficile pour vous ouais je
savais pas c'est un peu emmerdant
on comptait vous présenter l'un à
l'autre et tout mais là c'est un peu
raté
il était très beau déjà très sérieux
toujours sérieux vous voulez déjà et il
était surtout très bon footballeur et
non jouer contre lui c'était pas
toujours facile général je n'ai jamais
vu pendant les matches regardez dans les
tribunes ah ouais c'est pas comme toi
qui passe son temps à regarder déjà pris
un but est de garder lune
hu a commencé au ballon vous départ ça
marchait tellement bien qu'il a fait
comique parce que tout le monde lui
disait voilà comique
puis un jour il ali ben ben je vais
faire ça mais c'est marseille ouais
c'est pas cantona sais pas quand mais
qui manque un an c'est moi j'aimerais
bien essayer je vais dire un truc là
franchement je n'aurais jamais dit ça
même pas un mois ou deux mois avant mais
c'est vrai que guy roux même à marseille
ça pourrait ouais ils m'ont toujours
fait un accueil formidable je sais pas
pourquoi chaque fois que je vais à
marseille ils ont le droit comme ça
bon vivre heureux de vous avoir longé
pas vous faire trop de compliments on a
envie de vous faire des compliments mais
j'ai pas envie de faire trop de
compliments d'abord parce que c'est pas
le genre de la maison puis ensuite parce
que vous avez dit les louanges abbès
l'homme
oui c diminuent l'homme diminue la
combativité voilà sont pas de louanges
mais vous dis pas qu'on vous aimez vous
êtes formidables ne diminuait pas ma
combativité avec avec vous on en a
besoin
bon alors quand on s'intéresse un petit
peu à votre personne votre personnage
devient beaucoup plus clair en fait
c'est à dire on s'aperçoit dès qu'on
étudie un peu l'avis de guy roux les
ancêtres de guiraud on s'aperçoit que
finalement tout ça a été assez clair
vous avez retrouvé des traces de vos
ancêtres jusqu'au 12ème siècle
aujourd'hui on est dans une dans une
soirée que moyen-âge sais pas comment
dire il ya un bon gars et un bouquin
vous avez retrouvé dans le château
d'appoigny non mais c'est vrai ce que je
dis est alors ce qu'on découvre en fait
on est tout le temps guy roux il un bon
votre personnage dis pas que c'est la
vérité mais votre personnage aux
guignols c'est d'être un peu radin
d'être un peu et en fait vous avez des
ancêtres écossais oui c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit enfin de l'historien qui m'a
enseigné ma ma mère s'appelait laurie
voilà loris est un nom écossaise à la
danoise au ricoh c'est parce que le
château de ré jeune c'était la dernière
garnison de charles le téméraire et
c'était des soldats écossais bah là on
comprend mieux le sens de l'économie
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je le dis tout de
suite comme ça on n'aurait pas à le
ressortir la ressortir à la prochaine
émission
j'ai envoyé ma note de frais de voyage
pour venir y fier à votre produit
je savais pas
confrères comme vous à jouer sur ce côté
employé par les guignols c'est honnête
j'ai envoyé la note c'était la moindre
des choses
à un moment vous avez voulu attaquer les
guignols et donner l'argent à une cause
humanitaire
si vous avez dit gagnent de l'argent
avec moi y'a pas de raison qu'il ne paye
pas et l'argent je le donnerais à une
grande cause oui c'est un petit peu
c'était ma première idée après je me
suis aperçu que quand je disais qu'il
fallait qu'ils arrêtent ils en faisaient
plus donc j'ai un petit peu insisté brel
mais ça c'est pas fait finalement alors
vous quand on continue à chercher dans
votre famille vos ancêtres y avait un
ancêtre de guy roux qui préférait
prendre 50 coups de fouet que donner ses
récoltes au seigneur ça c'est une partie
de votre personnage et l'autre partie
votre côté imaginer mettre en place
vérifier c'est que vous êtes en fait un
adepte de napoléon j'aimais beaucoup
napoléon et un de vos à y aller tu es
grognards de napoléon il était sergent
dans la grande armée et il a eu la
légion d'honneur sur la bérézina c'était
le grand père de mon grand-père donc pas
tradition orale on est sûre il a pris un
coup de lances à la bérézina il est
revenu à pied il est arrivé sept ans
plus tard et on lui a dit napoléon alors
il a dit je sais pas vrai il est parti à
fontainebleau à pied toujours bien sûr
pour vérifier très grosse influence de
votre grand-père votre grand-père fameux
grand père qui est mort à 100 ans ont
lutté maladie voulait pas se coucher il
dit il y dix essais dans les lits qu'on
meurt juste le pen me coucher non il
disait je tant que j'irai dans le jardin
à la mort ne me trouvera pas et puis les
quelques dernières semaines ils
pouvaient plus sortir il a dit là va me
trouver et vous souvenez de votre
grand-père l'histoire de la deûle
ampoules électriques là quand vous avez
commencé à auxerre oui quand je suis en
arrêt je t'ai militaire en allemagne
quand je suis rentré
j'ai eu un studio au fait que le club
m'a trouvé mais le locataire précédent
avait enlevé les ampoules l'emmo grand
père m'a prêté les ampoules du grenier
mais m'a dit faut que tu gagnes ta vie
avant le printemps parce qu'au printemps
je retourne au grenier pour me la rendre
à grande influence ce grand-père
survenant surtout des bons principes
sont les bons principes c'est là que ça
vient parce que j'ai mis en évidence
elles qui m'ont permis d'avancer un
petit peu là vous êtes france profonde
mais pas franchouillard et ça je crois
que c'est important de le dire parce que
par exemple quand on voit vos
déclarations sur l'immigration
vous devez un discours qui est très
tolérant vous dites la france est une
terre d'invasion la première génération
c'est toujours difficile les polonais
des italiens il est portugais mais
finalement ces gens là ont enrichi notre
notre pays
oui parce que géographiquement c'était
c'est le bout de l'europe c'est l'ouest
de l'europe il pouvait pas aller plus
loin et par exemple pour parler toujours
d'histoire de ma région la vallée de
l'yonne et dans les invasions barbares
c'est elle et ses notes c'était en gros
des mongols et on trouve encore des gens
et les yeux [ __ ] dans les campagnes ça
fait pourtant longtemps et donc je pense
que toutes ces invasions fait par les
mélanges ont fait les français
et puis bon on maintenant ça vient il y
en a encore qui viennent de l'est je
pense volontiers entier c'est
désagréable mais nous avons des gens qui
viennent du sud maintenant il faut quand
même se rappeler que c'est d'abord nous
qui les avons envahi
c'est nous qui avons été chercher des
colonies il n'avait pas appelé
donc on a une culture commune qu'on a
partagé avec eux et maintenant avec les
moyens modernes de transport il arrive
je pense que il faut leur faire le
meilleur accueil sort et j'ai été
habitué au lycée parce que nous étions à
lisser d'accueil de l'afrique
occidentale française
il y avait dans chaque dortoir où dans
chaque classe 5 africains à peu près
qu'ils étaient des fils de riches et moi
j'étais avec eux leurs meilleurs copains
c'était ceux qui jouent au foot
évidemment
et en plus comme ils étaient riches ils
avaient des costumes tellement que ça tu
n'es pas dans leurs armoires il en
mettait dans la mienne est comme ça je
pourrais sortir le samedi vous êtes
tombés dans le football très jeunes
parce qu'un jour guy roux il avait 6 ans
on vous
dessine-moi le paradis vous avez dû
signer des pelous débuter un ballon donc
oui je suis toujours j'avais dit au curé
aux catéchistes que le paradis ça devait
être un endroit où il y avait plein de
terrain de foot avec des ballons et
depuis on m'a proposé on m'a dit et tu
sera l'entraîneur du paradis à ces jeux
l'argile dit le plus tard possible bien
sûr hélas comme j'étais petit on vous
offrait des soldats de plomb nous
faisait deux équipes au lieu un avec une
bille qui servait de ballons vous
arrivez pas se faire la guerre de
juillet au ballon j'étais enfant après
la guerre dont elle est jouée c'est
essentiellement des soldats de plomb
mais nous avec une bille on faisait des
équipes de foot avec le filet vous savez
les loyers les films de truffaut là et
les femmes avaient un filet pour le
chignon bret alors je prenais fils et de
ma mère ça faisait les filets de but et
mon métier un grand soldat dans les buts
power oui on mettait à kobaya général
ont bouché là parce qu'il plongeait sur
le vin sur la bi nzé toujours été chef 1
à 13 ans il était déjà le petit chef
vous occuper tout le monde vous confier
les ballons lestoille le terrain vous
l'aviez les shorts soigner les joueurs
non mais juste un petit peu
organisateurs des années plus tard quand
vous êtes à auxerre si vous aviez des
espions dont les boîtes de nuit pour
voir si les joueurs sortent et non au
début j'allais voir moi-même
ah bon malanje mal à en prenant plage
et les boîtes se multipliant j'ai
organisé un petit peu vous aviez un
réseau alors maintenant avec les
portables je vais vous dire c'est facile
car si vous avez un analyseur samedi
c'était un peu c'est à peut faire sur le
coup de 11h chérie je vais voir s'il ya
des joueurs en boîte de nuit
j'en ai cherché jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin enfin beaucoup pour sortir ça mais
adriana ils le font à karembeu sa dent
sans jamais à bon ok je vais vous dire
quand on vous à la maison en sort pas
clair battre en sortirait plus jamais
les boîtes ferait faillite
ouais alors vous avez toujours été quand
même très préoccupé par les copines des
joueurs tous à la taille des voitures il
paraît donc c'est vrai c'est incroyable
vous aimiez pas que les joueurs sortent
avec des filles qui avaient des airs 5
ou des fiat 500 parce que les mecs se
choper mal aux reins en [ __ ] dans la
voiture non c'est que un moment on avait
un centre de formation depuis trois ans
et donc on avait eu délit évidemment
après à prix réduit et un jour tous les
plusieurs joueurs avait mal au dos 1
alors le directeur du centre me dis il
faut changer l'élite acheter des livres
assez bien faut changer les lire je fais
une enquête ce qu'ils avaient tous les
trois une petite amie qui avait une fiat
500 vous avez des ruses aussi pour
rentrer dans les hôtels contient un
joueur qui vous intéressez vous faisiez
pas ces séries comme par exemple en
argentine je croyais 20 joueurs polonais
qui vous intéressait cette rentrée en
vous faisant passer pour un livreur de
boissons mais c'est à la coupe du monde
soixante dix huit l'équipe de pologne
était en altitude dans un col red en
altitude on augmente la faculté de
d'avoir des globules rouges
c'est d'une manière naturelle ce n'est
pas la même chose que c'est pas le pérou
voilà c'est ça mais ça fait le même
effet donc l'équipe de pologne était
dans un col à 15 cents mètres dans un
hôtel et il y avait là la troupe
argentine qui gardait c'était dans la
cordillère des andes
le petit gars de la route c'était
impossible de passer moi je voulais
contacter harmach qui était le grand
avant-centre de l'époque
eh bien j'ai dit ces gens là où ils
mangent ils boivent dont il ya des gens
qui leur portent la boisson j'ai trouvé
le livreur de bierges une casquette la
veste il est infernal
cheap quand je suis arrivé où il m'a dit
maintenant tu m'aides vous êtes interne
à la frma qu'à signer chez nous un an
plus tard il a signé chez nous deux en
prison plus tard vers les deux ans mais
n'avait le droit de sortir qu'à 30 ans à
ce moment là avant c'était du temps du
régime communiste guy alors il ya quand
même un peu le revers de la médaille
c'est à dire que j'ai tout donné à
auxerre j'ai aussi pratiquement la seule
équipe dont vous êtes occupé vous allez
vous l'avez pris à 0 et vous l'avez
mener au plus haut si vous a quand même
coûté votre vie affective non aux non
non non non j'ai une vie affective qui
doit correspondre à la moyenne des des
gens de notre société actuelle
non je ne me plains pas là dessus je ne
me plains pas du tout ça c'est pas
coûter votre mariage oh non parce que ya
des mariages qui vont pas où vous ne
versez pas des entraîneurs de foot assis
avec les entraîneurs de foot
alors vous êtes posé une question un
jour c'est vrai qu'on peut se la poser
pourquoi tout le monde aime tellement le
foot alors il ya plusieurs explications
il ya le ballon rond pour puisque ça
rappelle le ventre de la mère et puis
après quand on est adolescent
ça peut faire penser autre chose non
déjà bébé je vais me croiser les bras à
40 de l'école j'ai dit il j'ai dit bon
d'abord le évidemment le ventre de la
mère de l'enfant il commence dans une
sphère
ensuite il va chercher son casse croûte
dans les sphères ensuite quand il est
adolescent comme vous avez dit il a
plutôt tendance à s'en rapprocher encore
bon ensuite il ya la lune ya la terre
varie beaucoup de se faire et je pense
que c'est une d une des choses qui a
tiré pour ce à quoi tout le monde le
monde entier est attiré par le bal en ce
moment oui les jeux de ballons sont sans
mondiaux pas seulement le football a le
le basket aussi le volet qui sont des
transports mondiaux le handball mais y
met le rugby c'est le rugby c'est un
autre type de gonzesses
non mais bon personne ne saura jamais
pourquoi les philosophes essayer de
chercher karembeu il joue avec deux
ballons lui et alors
merci
je suis vivant je suis d'accord d'accord
d'accord l'homme vous dites aussi que
l'homme quand il joue au ballon
il retrouve ses quatre membres alors
c'est pourquoi c'est vous pensez que
c'est à un retour de l'époque où mariah
carey des messages e enfin moi je suis
pas bien étudié mais mais il semblerait
un moment qu'on n'ait eu des ancêtres
qui avait un peu des mains à la place
des pieds un très bon et tout d'un coup
quand l'homme s'est redressé les pieds
non plus servi qu'à marcher à se tenir
demain
oui c'est vrai qu'avant d'être appelé
les branches accueilli avec les quatre
les quatre mains fiction le pied à
diminuer les qualités a diminué ses
qualités a perdu des qualités c'est
peut-être ça le football c'est
l'activité humaine qui a permis de
rendre le pied intelligent et bien voilà
tout le monde vous croient comme ça
[Musique]
et en fait vous êtes
bio à l'appel le sorcier bourguignons
sur scène jamie sympathy for the devil
parce qu'on vous appelle le sorcier
bourguignon est alors c'est vrai que
vous avez un don mais c'est vrai un de
voyance à attendait guy d'abord je vais
citer quelques exemples très très précis
que l'on ne peut vérifier fait le
service militaire en allemagne
un jeu vous allez voir votre supérieur
hiérarchique le gradé dit il faut que je
m'en aille pourquoi ma mère vient de
mourir
c'était vrai et vous saviez pas le
terrible est arrivé le lendemain je
pense que beaucoup de gens ont ce genre
de la bande de prémonition validé le 10
sport moi je le lâche et un jour et puis
c'est répéter mais je pense que ça
arrive à beaucoup de monde ça est votre
joueur là michel ngom là vous étiez le
premier sur les lieux
un jour c'est le hasard alors vous est
ce que c'est le hasard
soit parce qu'il paraît que vous
prédisiez bien les résultats des matchs
le score le nom du buteur les
circonstances du but
ça m'arrive mais je ne le dit jamais et
ça ça n'arrive pas toujours parfois il
ya des erreurs mais quand même dans des
matchs très forts des matches ou des
finales cécile fait j'avais un souci la
faculté d'anticipation a exacerbé de
voilà que c'est juste pour dire
[Applaudissements]
ce qui veut dire qu'ils venaient à fait
d'accord je vais me concentrer sur un
match vous finissez par sentir
complètement récemment le prévoir
et je sors ces bourguignons bien alors
attention là maintenant on va vous faire
une interview proverbe savait qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfait voila voila je dis ça je dis ça
pour lambie laurent si tu nous regardes
ton lieu de vacances avec les gosses ça
ce que des gens comme guy roux ne bouge
pas eu
voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
alors l'interview proverbe
attention vous êtes prêts est ce que
vous pensez guy roux que tant va la
cruche à l'eau qu'à la fin elle se casse
oui croyez vous qu'on puisse être au
four et au moulin
non faut-il absolument ménager sa
monture quand on veut voyager loin
oui estimez vous que la paresse et la
mère de tous les vices
non à pourquoi il ya deux ans il
yad'autres mère de tous les vices
ah oui sûrement ouais plus grave plus
grave que l'appareil par exemple la
tendance à la malhonnêteté par la wii la
paresse c'est une
c'est une négation mais c'est pas
vraiment une faute en soi je trouve
c'est pas un défaut il a construit toute
sa carrière sur l'année sur la paresse
il se donne du mal pour être je peux
vous dire est ce que vous pensez guy
roux que pour vivre heureux il faut
vivre caché
ben non ça c'est pas ma vie je vais pas
me cacher bah je serais pas venu soir
ouais ça c'est vrai voilà qu'en tant que
vous soyez là ça me fait très plaisir
vous soyez moi je dirai après si j'étais
quand est ce qu'on va aller franchement
que pierre qui roule ne peut pas amassé
bout ce nom ouais vous n'êtes pas
toujours d'accord avec la sagesse
populaire avec la non parce que vous
savez vous dit vous ne donnez des
proverbes il ya très souvent le proverbe
inverse
ouais alors moment donné un mois je
préfère l'autre il est malin est-ce que
vous pensez que bien mal acquis ne
profite jamais oui oui ça d'accord
est-ce que tout vient à point à qui sait
attendre we were presque toujours
c'est comme le proverbe chinois assieds
toi à bord de la rivière et tu verra
passer le cadavre de ton pire ennemi
c'est ça un peu oui en biens chinois
celui-là vous avez des proverbes comme
ça de rihanna dans votre pays
belinda au boulot ce serait un mensonge
à des petites jambes
oui c'est ça quand même temps c'est pas
cech d'ailleurs excusé moi c'est ça j'ai
slovaque
allez c'est quoi la différence se
vendent pas la différence
ça veut dire quoi j'ai pas compris je
sais pas si tous y compris le hockey
voilà qu'est ce qui veut dire la
signification de mensonges et des
petites jambes ça veut dire quoi
si vous mentez vous n'allez pas très
loin
[Applaudissements]
et si la sagesse novak bien alors qu'ils
roulent dernière question est-ce que
mieux vaut tard que jamais ou vieux
motard que j'aimais répondez vous êtes
obligé tard que jamais merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui vais sortir un bouquin je
montre ma caméra voit la guy roux zoom
zoom mon garçon écrit avec serge mésonès
erigène saccomano de dos le double d'où
ces verrous sur le phocéa tu peux zoom
est mon garçon au ca donne à la baie
l'entraineur de ma vie il ya quoi danse
libre
c'est un petit peu les dernières années
parce que il y en avait 1 précédemment
écrit en 93 contre les fous de foot et
là comme beaucoup de gens ont été
intrigués de mon arrêt soudain il voyait
à cet esprit il fallait l'annoncer au
plus grand nombre comme ça et pas besoin
d'y revenir mais j'y suis revenu quand
même un petit peu dans ce livre et puis
serge mésonès gène saccomano qui me
connaissent bien serge mésonès et mon
ancien capitaine de la finale de la
coupe de 79 qu'ils sont journalistes
gueule forme il a affronté quand tu
écris tous les deux donc ça s'appelle
entraîneur de ma vie guy roux sortira
seulement fin novembre c'est ce que je
voulais dire là sa sortie va seulement
fin novembre attention
hop hop hop des gentils mon garçon mais
qu'il est apprenti il est apprenti chez
tout le monde en parle il fait pas les
mains vas-y j'ai vu sa vie est ce que ça
veut dire c'est chez les sourds muets
vous auriez pu bien moi je le sais je le
dis pas quoi c'est quoi je te dire après
l'émission
alors quelques emails avant de continuer
alors monsieur masure
je me dis je ne suis pas bruno masure
parce qu'il faut extraire une masure je
suis m'appelle masure alors lui veut
toujours faire c'est celui qui vous ai
pas suivi mais il veut qu'on fasse
l'interview strip tease je vous pose des
questions et puis si vous répondre je
trouve ça ridicule personnellement moi
je trouve vraiment ah non c'est lourd
ouais là l'interview au moyen âge
c'était et lauriane un e-mail génial un
mec qui me dit pourquoi vous invitez
jamais de charlie parker et john
coltrane et qu'on vienne pas me dire
qu'ils sont morts petit est-ce que tu
charlie parker et john coltrane peuvent
mourir
j'adore ça
il s'appelle jean jacques paladini
moment et maintenant maintenant mesdames
messieurs nous allons accueillir en
ressuscité voici patrick dupont
ah ah
patrick dupond bonsoir bonsoir a tous
voila je reste comme ça je suis bien je
suis installé tout va bien merci au
revoir merci d'être venus il vous reste
une offre enfin bon c'est pas le même
usage 800 cas il va pousser tout va bien
tout va bien alors dans la série dupond
et dupont
la semaine dernière on avait aurélie
dupont et cette semaine on à patrick
dupond voilà donc vous vous la
connaissez aurélie dupont cela d'or
c'est une de mes chouchous tu voues
grande que rien et c'est une très très
belle danseuse surtout coup du mec plein
de choses dans la tête aller a lancé ici
qu'elle était toute seule vous savez que
cette émission servent à ça aussi
patrice rapace a longtemps alors vous et
vous c'est incroyable quoi c'est retour
de l'enfer mais ouais ouais 6 janvier
2004 - sur un lit d'hôpital et alors à
l'époque vous étiez allongé comme ça
c'était le tour de normandie
j'étais allongé il vous entendiez les
pompiers qui disait vidéo et avec
patrick dupont il est pas beau à voir
il est pas beau à voir mais il s'en
sortira ouais ouais mais ce qui est
formidable c'est que exactement dix mois
jour pour jour après cet accident
c'est à dire dans trois jours le rideau
se lève à l'espace pierre cardin et qui
est-ce qui danse et qui est ce qu'il
chante que c'est bibi se dire et donc
quelque part bah ouais voilà
[Applaudissements]
mais sans que ça m'arrive à moi ça peut
arriver aux autres les sportifs ont une
faculté de se rétablir
il ya les sportifs et gérard depardieu
ces deux catégories
non mais c'est vrai il faut être fort
alors donc j'ai tout repris à zéro vous
avec votre votre père votre maître max
bozzoni donc j'étais allé dans des
données vous dites dans les studios il
ya des petites ballerines de six ans
j'ai tout recommencé durée rodier avec
des petites filles de 6 et des petits
garçons de 6 et 7 ans qui m'ont regardé
avec des yeux un peu halluciné j'ai
recommencé doucement avec lui et puis
quelques semaines plus tard j'étais sur
la scène de l'espace cardin et je
commençais à re danser à chanter et à
jouer la comédie et c'est bien je suis
super content si vous voyez un homme
heureux là bas alors la comédie musicale
s'appelle l'air de paris c'est de 7
novembre à l'espace cardin
alors c'est basé sur quoi surtout les
grands airs de parler mais c'est aussi
bien ses 45 chansons en fait on a
choisis dans le répertoire de toutes les
chansons qui étaient écrites sur paris
45 des plus belles qui sont des
certaines des vrais chef-d'oeuvre des
bijoux tels la complainte de la butte la
valse à mille temps rue de lappe pigalle
neterra est en fait c'est l'histoire
d'une pro du jeune provinciale qui au
milieu landowski et manon landowski le
jour de son mariage au moment de dire
oui a dit non on dit mais attend pour
quad était dingue on peut pas dire non
c'est épouser un héritier un riche
héritier est dit mais enfin vous avez
rien compris à paris qui m'attend et
elles sont dans le train d'harry elle
arrive à paris dans un dancing dans le
patron c'est moi et je lui dis alors
cocotte tu veux voir paris donne moi la
main je la prend par la main et je dis
regarde là bas à droite c'est la rue de
la paix de l'otan joyeux voilà ça y est
ça commence comme ça quand vous chantez
la wii je sente se sentent à peu près 40
chansons
vous avez une bonne capacité pulmonaire
pour vous c'est pareil j ouer j'ai 5
litres à peu près 5 litres à quelque 2
days d'oxygène ça va très très bien
celle là ne sont plus que la normale
et c'est quoi exactement comme un
accordéon notre prof de chant nous dit
toujours regarder roland quand ils
ouvrent comme ça et donc car le vent ces
sas ou alors un patrick dupont au
printemps un livre est sorti qu'il
s'appelle étoiles voilà que je suis
fayard
et alors on apprend pas mal de choses
sur vous c'est un homme destiné à ces
étonnantes
d'abord vous n'êtes pas connu votre père
non j'ai même pas si les partis ou si
votre mère l'a mis dehors vous savez
maintenant les blés contre 10,2 mois
suivant suivant la personne qui raconte
l'histoire ces troubles tout ce qu'il ya
d'important en tous les cas c'est qu'il
ya six ans je les rencontrer pour la
première fois par hassli s'y attendait
c'est génial d'histoire d'abord tu veux
dire vous avez été élevé donc par votre
beau père lucien l'espace de l'atelier
ma grand mère et un jour racontez nous
cette histoire en thalasso en 94 c'est
extraordinaire on était en thalasso
après après les soins et le dîner du
soir on se faisait une petite coupette
de champagne tranquille
youtube a voté et le barman vient vers
nous y voilà il ya le monsieur là bas au
fond à gauche qui vous offre une
bouteille de dom pérignon
alors je renvoie la bouteille en disant
non dit au monsieur là bas que j'accepte
pas le champagne des messieurs que je
connais pas puis le monsieur insiste une
fois puis deux fois puis trois puis à
chaque fois je renvoie en direct et non
je suis pas libre toute façon ce soir et
je suis avec ma mère donc un peu de
décence s'il vous plaît qui garde son
champagne on verra ça plus tard
éventuellement puis il insiste encore ma
mère ne regarde et me dit écoute tu
devrais regarder à gauche quand même je
regarde comme cela je dis on je la fais
tu vas tu vas te marrer mais le mec là
on dirait moi avec vingt ans de plus et
20 kg de plus me dis bah ouais je dis
quoi bein ouai dit bah ouais 20 ans de
plus et 20 kg s'est effectivement vrai
c'est ton père oui un vieux blancs la
highway assez énorme alors besoin de son
père il aime dit oui c'est ton père et
j'ai fait signe au monsieur puis il est
venu on s'est serré la main
il a regardé ma mère est là j'ai compris
j'ai dit ok je voulais ce whisky dvd
c'est un leader et puis j'ai compris
brialy
ce que vous avez compris en fait c'est
que vous avez vu leur regard vous avez
vu je regardais vous ai dit j'ai passé
un truc très fort en dur par des gens
s'aiment aussi fort que quand je suis né
ma mère avait 16 ans et demi lui de ne
pas en avoir beaucoup plus c'est bon il
s'est passé évidemment et quand ils se
sont revus comme ça au bout de 36 ans
ouais 35 ans donc j'ai vu dans leurs
yeux qu'ils se passait quelque chose je
les ai laissés ensuite survenue j'ai dit
bon on va la boire cette bouteille mais
on va se parler un peu quand même parce
qu'on ne peut pas en rester là et donc
on a parlé jusqu'à 4 5 heures du matin
on a descendu six ou sept bouteilles
je n'ai pas conduit après et donc on est
rentrés tranquille et puis maintenant se
voient presque assez régulièrement j'ai
découvert que chez lui chez votre vrai
père il y avait une pièce qui vous était
dédiée en plus en allant chez us était
une espèce de mausolées patrick dupond
j'ai dit tu vas m'arracher tout ça il y
avait des photos de moi partout four à
tous les âges de ma vie dans ma
nomination danseur étoile ma nomination
de directeurs quand j'ai été décoré de
chevalier des arts et lettres
mais c'est pas possible tu peux pas
vivre il va être très malheureuse envers
patrice finalement parce que je suis je
suis autre chose que ce à quoi d'être
malheureux de vous voir réussir comme ça
ne pas pouvoir vous le dira pas pouvoir
vous parler c'est sa chance et cette
histoire là aussi l'histoire de barbara
ah ben oui a raconté nous livrons
monsieur tout le monde sait ça les noms
parus est arrivé la même aventure elle a
trouvé son père plus près tard fait
appel à elle l'a ratée en plus que vous
avez malheureusement il a disparu et
elle a écrit nantes
ouais voilà dans le train qui la
ramenait après l'enterrement la vie vous
savez tout non mais j'ai quelques relais
dans les chanteurs c'est barbara léo
ferré brel brassens
jusqu'ici tout va bien vient alors la
vocation de vous traîtres et aux vous
avez été découvert votre votre vocation
parce que quand vous aviez trois ans le
dimanche après le repas familial fameux
repasse le fameux repas du dimanche
qu'on a tous connu avec le monbazillac
et b et les gâteaux secs vous montiez
debout sur la table convenait de
débarrasser puis avait le mange disque
rouge et donc sur twist again je dansais
là au milieu de la table il y avait mon
grand père avec sa deuxième femme ma
grand mère qui était l'épousé de mon
grand père avec son deuxième mari et ma
mère avec lucien son deuxième mari voilà
et sa forme est une espèce de pyramides
et moi j'étais en haut de la pyramide
les gens dansaient twist again comme ça
j'avais 3 ans jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que je
tombe d'épuisement jeu que vous oubliez
dans votre culotte
c'était un plaisir attendez vous
imaginez le public en or vous avez une
énergie donc extraordinaire à l'époque
donc vous dossier jusqu'à jusqu'à plus
soif dimanche après-midi sur la table de
la cuisine familiale mais très jeune on
découvre chez vous une énergie
extraordinaire vous dormez trois quatre
heures par nuit quand j'avais 14 ans
vous êtes un peu le chef de la bande
en fait les 400 coups on vous appelle
tape dur et vous êtes agité et colérique
un peu épileptique et votre mère et
c'est comme ça qu'il est devenu
patrick dupond votre mère vous en faire
dans une chambre obscure membres lors sa
chance nous sommes sur le grand lit
enfin la chambre de lucien et de l
éternel lumière et elle me laisse en
compagnie de jacques brel edith piaf léo
ferré mais aussi mozart mahler et
charles et rythm and blues est sûr c est
à chaque fois qu'elle met la musique je
me calme alors là les amis bottemer demi
au judo à ce moment là au judo au dojo
et vous êtes arrivé la même histoire
quand aurélie dupont
un jour elle va je puis à quelques cours
elle entend de la musique elle marche
jusqu'à la grande salle d'où venait la
musique et c'était un cours d'essai est
un coup de dents voilà ça a été pour
elle la révélation et pour vous c'est
exactement la même chose si j'ai fondu
en larmes j'ai été bouleversée parce que
c'était arthur rubinstein
en fait c'était encore un mange disque
le professeur de danse pour accompagner
ses cours de danse mettez des disques de
rubinstein qui jouait chopin ouais et là
c'était la fantaisie impromptu
je m'en souviendrai vraiment toute ma
vie je suis resté et il y avait des
filles qui dansaient c'était beau elle
était belle
j'ai trouvé ça magnifique et donc j'ai
filé en kimono réveillé ma mère c'était
un dimanche matin brrr et donc je les ai
tiré au cours j'ai dit qu'est ce que
c'est madhi mais c'est un cours de danse
est dit mais je veux faire ça m'a dit tu
peux pas juger mais pourquoi me dis
parce que faut être le meilleur du monde
pour faire ça et 10 mai mais je lui dis
mes meilleurs du monde mais c'est ça que
je veux faire élire vos parents qui
étaient pas très fortunés un les
vengeances drôlement et des années
roulait pas sur l'or mais vous ont
drôlement aider à réussir à faire à
faire ce que vous voulez ils vous ont
surtout trouvé votre entraîneur votre
coach vous mettre votre maigre neppert c
max bozzoni vin qu'ils étaient une ex
étoile de l'opéra un jour votre mère ait
dans un pressing l'avenue de versailles
a dit vous connaissez pas quelqu'un qui
pourrait donner des cours à mon fils
c'est une dame qui dit mon ex mari
et voilà et oui mon ex mari professeur
il peut s'occuper votre fils est donc on
est arrivé chez max frérot diarra
pigalle là-haut et j'avais mes chaussons
de pointe à la main il me dit c'est quoi
ça je dis bah ce sont mes chaussons très
fier dit mais les garçons ils font pas
les points tout âge dit ah bon ils font
pas les pointes et beach house café j'ai
un tapis lundi bien on s'en va il
connaît rien à la danse celui là on s'en
va et puis trois jours plus tard j'ai
réfléchi un peu je me suis dit c'est pas
très intelligent ce que je fais donc on
va y aller quand même
alors voilà donc vous travailler le soir
avec lui vous êtes au corps de ballet de
l'opéra enfin vous commencez à prendre
enfin vous êtes à 15 ans et demi vous
vous êtes dispensé par le ministère du
travail quand j'étais en gamme à 15 ans
il alors vous décidé de préparer varna
en varna il faut expliquer ce que c'est
c'est des jeux olympiques de la danse
les jeux olympiques c'est à dire qu'il
ya quasiment tous les pays représentés
il ya 750 concurrents vous décidez de
faire varma lucien à votre beau père
meurt ce qui est quand même facilite pas
les choses
vous y allez c'est en juillet 76 et la
dernière épreuve au moment fatidique la
bande magnétique sur laquelle vous
dansez casse un sac à ce qu'elles soient
liées une fille qui monte sur le sur
scène quelqu'un du public à jouer ils
jouent qui a joué du piano pour mouais
et voilà et je remporte le jackpot à
dire la ville dort et même pas été donné
tu dis
ouais c'était baryshnikov le et là votre
carrière explose êtes une star
patrick dupond 17 ans kadri de l'opéra
il vient de remporter le grand prix du
festival international de danse de varna
un triomphe éclatant puisque ce prix n'a
été attribué que deux fois depuis la
fondation du concours en 1964 de la
graine des toiles dit on déjà
et
[Musique]
et l'on
oh
e
et voilà ça c'est fait 1976 alors on va
faire toute la carrière de patrick
dupond non plus jusqu'à quand tout est
dans le livre
faut lire ce bouquin alors bon après il
les problèmes avec l'opéra on va pas on
va pas en parler si ce n'est que vous
venez de gagner quand même un million et
demi de francs parce que vous avez été
viré de façon un peu illégal et donc
vous venez de gagner votre procès contre
l'opéra de paris
donc vous avez un million et demi de
francs oui ça correspond au salaire que
j'ai pas perçu pendant trois ans et demi
et ça correspond surtout à l'argent que
je vais pouvoir mettre de côté pour ma
retraite quoi parce que nous les
danseurs moi j'ai 41 ans pour le pour
l'opéra je suis un vieux palaja
je suis fini et là il ya eu après votre
période noire c'est à dire vous avez eu
comme on dit les boules kouassi au vu
des ganglions au cou est fait opérer
outre été diagnostiquée ont recherché le
cancer enfin bon je suis passé par toute
une série d'épreuves pas drôle parce que
la série noire c'est après la lumière je
suis plongé dans l'eau nous enlève les
ganglions touche amère est paralysé du
bras ensuite tombé dans l'escalier où
j'écris le livre pour faire leur
éducation j'ai commencé ça je m'appelle
vous tombé dans l'escalier
bg avoue près de sa maison à à montreux
pour allez vous reposer elle brûle pas
vous étiez vraiment pensé que c'était
mieux après le quatrième et cinquième
matin le 5e c'était le soir maurice
m'appelle en disant écoute je suis à
osaka en est en juillet tu croiras
jamais aimé il fait un froid de canard
ça me fait penser qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent du feu et je lui mets tous les
soirs j'en fais vous inquiétez pas
mauricie fait pas froid dans le chalet
ouais donc le soir en bonne élève je
fais un bon petit feu puis je me
couchais vers 10h30 et à 4 heures du
matin tout brûle avec moi d'or le chalet
brûle avec moi les chiens et le
manuscrit du livre et dont ils entendent
sauver les chiens d'abord le manuscrit
ensuite et mon pyjama prévu l'accident
et on a parlé tout à l'heure donc le 6
janvier 2010 voilà puis aujourd'hui vous
êtes là et on est ravi qu'il est dans
trois jours et oui dans trois jours le
rideau se lève et je suis vraiment le
rôle bien mais on est très heureux
content et il se relèvera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vient alors patrick dupont va faire une
interview dernier moubarak dans la
jungle
[Musique]
dès que ma fille est plus là voilà je
constate que cette personne bouge merci
ça me fait très plaisir et je tiens
beaucoup à ça alors dernier coup c'est
facile dernier coup dur panier goody en
accident de voiture l'accident dernier
coup de coeur coups de coeur
adriana karembeu je comprends le dernier
dernier passait il ya 5 minutes ou qu'on
consomme avait bien dans les coups de
poing dernier coup de poing le procès
ouais là des coups de folie
l'un des coups de folie un très joli
cadeau pour maman dernier coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre roba petit
partenaire maintenant landowski naoui
fab bien les coups de gueule dernier
coup de gueule je veux qu'on m'écoute
aux répétitions
ah oui je veux travailler alors il veut
répéter je trouve qu'on passe trop de
temps sur les autres passez sur moi bien
les coups de bluff dernier coup de bluff
quand est ce que je fais je bluffe tout
le temps mais souffre la vie sauve ce
soir vous pouvez pas ici un dernier coup
de barre dernier coup de barbe c'était
ce matin à 10h30 jeudi accroché à la
barre
ah oui dernier avec lui c'est normal
bienvenue coup de blues
dernier coup de blues oh la la
il ya ba ya deux jours je rentre à la
maison crevé il était minuit et demi je
mets la radio évidemment c'est barbara
qui chante l'aigle noir et chutes du
niagara
ça m'est arrivé avec le raf a vu en main
[Applaudissements]
oh
bien bien des coups de poker dernier
coup de poker je serais tenté de dire le
procès aussi parce qu'on sait jamais si
on va gagner ou perdre et heureusement
or là c'est la justice qui a gagné donc
tomber la tension patrick dupond dernier
couvre un dernier coup de rein pas plus
tard qu'avant-hier soir ça s'est bien
passé
or génial
[Applaudissements]
ah oui c'est comme ça il signe un arrêt
peut tout dire ici vous savez quand on
dit tout le monde en parle ça veut pas
dire que tout le monde en parle ça veut
dire que tout le monde en parle bien
vous vous intéressez à l'astrologie vous
intéresse-t-il peu puisqu'il ya quatre
ans je rencontre quelqu'un que je
connaissais pas me dit 4,50 d'ailleurs
me dire oh la la il ya un tunnel noir je
m'y attendais je suis directeur de la
danse à l'opéra ça va merci
et puis en fait tout ce qu'elle m'a dit
dans l'état vous croyez au surnaturel ou
si vous avez vu lucien pour dire que le
problème j'ai été confronté à des
expériences vraiment un petit peu comme
guy avec la mort de sa maman quand le au
moment où lucien est mort j'étais en
train de dîner avec une copine quai de
jemmapes lui il était à
brie-comte-robert et dans la baie vitrée
j'ai vu son visage comment les d'un seul
coup ils n'étaient pas là et qu'elle
quelques heures plus tard on apprenait
qu'il était mort alors elle a précisé
wim est apparu nous croyons l'astrologie
vous lisez les horoscopes parce que ça
d'être up
oui ça fait peur voilà on va voir on va
voir quelqu'un qui a prouvé par la
science le fondement de l'astrologie
c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaissait plutôt
pour avoir été le mari de brigitte
bardot
mais là il a fait quelque chose d'autre
ouais c'est gunter sachs
[Musique]
gunter sachs bonsoir il a pensé avoir
l'habitude des jolies femmes du don
quatrième à 42 alors voilà vous êtes
surtout comme je disais et gunter sachs
connu en france surtout comme un playboy
milliardaire que vous avez été puisque
par votre mère vous et héritier de la
fortune des von poehl et par votre père
de la fortune des fichten en saxe vous
êtes connu comme photographe
vous êtes connu comme documentariste
vous êtes connus comme amateur d'art
vous avez dirigé le musée d'art moderne
de munich vous avez été ami avec andy
warhol avec salvador dali être quelqu'un
de très éclectique
comme je le disais vous avez épousé
brigitte bardot évidemment pour les
français brigitte bardot c'est notre
devoir national donc là la personne qui
la hait vous êtes aussi ses lettres
qu'elle est là vous revenez avec un
livre avec un indice très étonnant qui
n'a rien à voir avec tout ça et qui est
un livre passionnant voilà attention
gunther faire les mains or donc
attention winter
bien bien bien bien alors donc le
bouquin de gunter sachs s'appelle le
dossier astrologie ou la preuve
scientifique qu'il existe un lien entre
les signes du zodiaque et le
comportement humain c'est édité chez
michel lafon et c'est un best seller
international sas est déjà vendu
énormément en allemagne et puis la
version anglaise s'est vendu dans le
monde entier
alors c'est vrai bon moi personnellement
par exemple suis pas dingue d'astrologie
mais c'est vrai que chaque fois que je
rencontre un capricorne ou une
capricorne et qu'on discute on
s'aperçoit qu'on a beaucoup de
similitudes donc je me suis toujours dit
a peut-être un truc vrai là dedans et
alors voilà vous vous avez fait un truc
que jamais personne n'avait fait avant
vous vous avez analysé 15 millions de
données sur les mariages les divorces
les maladies les suicides les études les
les professions les la conduite les
délits pendant trois ans et vous avez
démontré grâce à sa l'influencent
mesurable des signes du zodiaque sur le
caractère humain c'est ça ce texte oct
ce qu'a fait greenpeace sachs qu'il a
les moyens de le faire évidemment comme
il dit pour le prix d'une porsche il a
monté un institut et vous avez fait
traiter les données à travers grandes
enquêtes statistiques que vous avez
faits corroborés par l'université de
munich donc c'est pas un truc été fait
en l'air et on s'aperçoit effectivement
que ben il ya des similitudes dans les
signes c'est ça oui par exemple le la
chose que nous avons seulement des dates
officielles
c'était uniquement des offices et ils
nous ont donné les données sont des gens
fils est alloué alors là évidemment au
début c'était un peu difficile parce
qu'ils disent est ce c'est contre la loi
on peut pas donner une date que
quelqu'un qui par exemple de se suicider
un truc et puis nous avons dit mais
donnez nous
capricorne les poissons et les choses et
alors là ça marche et on a trouvé des
choses très très z qu'on a lorsqu'on
trouve qu'ils ont trouvé c'est par
exemple il ya plus de suisse je dis
n'importe quoi mais il ya plus de
suicides chez les jumeaux que dans tout
autre si c'est ça hein
il ya plus de mariages qui
s'interrompent chez les sagittaire il ya
plus de des vrais et d'evry lignes de
force qui apparaît c'est ça que vous
avez démontré par exemple les
capricornes je sais pas quoi ils sont
sur représentés chez les dealers ben
j'en ai vendu il ya longtemps
comment vous savez ça on peut dire six
axes les fondements d'astrologie sont
scientifiquement mesurable c'est la
première fois où vous avez établi sur un
plan rationnel les fondements de
l'astrologie
on a cherché donc les les couples qui se
marient le plus alors le couple qui se
marie le plus sévère sous verse au sénat
et puis on a regardé les autres
ils ont donc la plus grande attraction
et dans les attractions on a tout d'un
coup eu un résultat étonnant c'est que
tous les 12 cl en france en allemagne
c'est un tout petit peu différent tous
les 12 signes aime se marier avec le
même s'il voit là mais essaie de
démontrer scientifiquement que ça avec
une certitude
enfin que ce n'est pas de la zad 50,1
milliards à placer ça tombe bien ça
c'est fou
c'est cette histoire comment j'ai passé
je sais pas combien de repas td avec
dédain alors moi c'est quand ça ce
bouquin et toi mais quand tu as assez
facile parce qu'une fois que facebook a
tu rencontres une bonne foi tu as tu tu
peux savoir puisque c'est basé sur les
statistiques témoignent
voilà c'est incroyable car c'est fou
cette histoire ça j'y perds ça marche
vierge et sagittaire d'une terre vierge
il faut que je viens de livres et sa
vitesse kunter après l'émission vous
pouvez donner un cours particulier
on doit il faut pas voir ça comme ça
dans l'hémisphère sud
oui non pas le même ciel que nous donc
ça marche pas du tout d'accord
[Musique]
si je n'ai
j'en suis là
non
voilà j'ai soit là rien que quand on
regarde la nuit quand on commence à
regarder les étoiles comme ça commence à
se poser souvent des mois je vois par
exemple qu'on se poser des questions
existentielles ce qu'on fait sur la
terre ce qui est un peu le big boss hugo
boss du foot vous êtes du cancer vous
êtes du cancer peut se penser ça très
sensible pour soi même at il n'a plus de
secret pour vous auriez avantage des
communistes avec l'échappée tu confonds
avec gunter grass bien alors je disais
donc le tout à l'heure pour nous avant
d'avoir publié ce bouquin que encore une
fois va être sûrement un succès en
france parce qu'en france tout le monde
est très très intéressé par l'astrologie
pour nous les français vous étiez
ici
et voilà alors bon brigitte bardot a
déclaré quand je pense qu avec gunter
sachs ont fréquenté les mêmes gens ont
fréquenté les mêmes endroits
on ne se connaissait pas savez-vous
maison était à côté à saint tropez à
l'époque au milieu des années 60 at on
entendu qu'on soit vous connaissez pas
et elle a déclaré c'est lui que
j'attendais voilà que quand elle vous a
rencontré des chez lui que j'attendais
alors bon vous êtes marié las vegas en
huit minutes mais à riaz orchestrée par
ted kennedy l époque vous êtes pelé
monsieur charest madame bordas pour être
incognito messieurs charest madame
bordas et puis donc c'est une histoire
d'amour qui a fait la une des médias et
le voyage de notes sur tout mais je
corrige
je veux joie joue contre nous mêmes
vous deux
regardez
je veux gagner ce choeur à coeur
et c'est mon jeu par coeur alors
sans prix chez je voulais tout
m
j'ai gagné tant pis c'est bien fait vous
êtes mon joueur présent
va plus vous mets toi
et tu feras ça t'apprendra n'importe
quoi pour moi
[Musique]
alors dites quoi le jour on vous avait
pris un hélicoptère et vous avez jeté
des roses sur la madrague la ville à
brigitte bardot à saint tropez
c'était avant le mariage s'est cependant
voulu draguer ou c'était après le voyage
et c'était un peu la main après alors
bon
brigitte bardot a parlé de vous dans ses
livres et elle dit et c'est très très
très bien pour vous elle dit c'était dur
de vivre avec moi j'étais pas un petit
morceau
il fallait un cas un caractère à la
gunter sachs qui s'est pas laissé faire
1 et elle dit en parlant de votre de son
histoire avec vous c'est un des seuls
moments de ma vie où j'ai réellement été
impressionnée ébloui par quelqu'un donc
voilà alors voilà ouais elle a aussi dit
autre chose
mais les femmes ce team
mais quand vous êtes discuter at il
relaté dit autre chose non mais ceci
étant il ya et bien non il ya eu un
problème
[Musique]
à
oui il ya eu un problème c'est que je
suis pas si c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé va nous dire mais j'ai
l'impression de brigitte bardot à un
moment elle a rencontré serge gainsbourg
oui la fin d'une chanson avec quinze
jours y'a pas une aventure et puis je
lui ai dit je voudrais pas que tu sautes
se disent qu'elle n'a pas sorti
ouais bah oui il est sorti avec jane
russell mais ya pas eu d'histoires entre
bardot et gainsbourg de ce soit il faut
la demander l ouais enfin moi elle me
l'a pas dit donc la version a été
censurée la version bardot gainsbourg
était censuré pour pas vous pourquoi
vous choquer pour vous faire de la peine
et donc ses sorties avec birkin
oui voilà le laisser terminer quelques
temps après votre histoire et bardos
brousseau en ont souvent un an et demi
plus tard mais un an et demi bardos
c'est oui comme souvent c'est pas facile
facile et on comprend ses réceptions la
connaissez d'autres gloires nationales
on la connaît bien maintenant adriana
karembeu qui est notre gloire nationale
beaucoup plus gentil adrienne je suis
gentil oui j'ai plus gentille que vous
êtes est facile à dire
non ah oui très très gentille pas tout
vous êtes sage qu'est ce qui à la veille
du pied les supporter cela attention
rihanna attention vous savez que vous
savez que gunter sachs a failli épouser
non seulement il a épousé bardot mais il
a failli poser soraya la femme du shah
d'iran attend des oreilles à la fin de
chacun des bunds earth acc c'était
maintenant vous êtes s'est rangé des
voitures vous êtes sages maintenant
quelque chose logique dans dans mon
livre j'ai trouvé que le dernier couple
qui ce divorce le plus et qui va pas du
tout jeune gémeaux un scorpion et ma
famille et mon masque or c'est
exactement marié vinck lire absolument
ça fait 30 ans qu'on est ensemble
donc ça met un peu en péril
effectivement ce que vous dites dans
votre bouquin cirque largement les
normands ça devrait pas marché bardot
elle s'était balancer vous scorpions 1,6
effet pour marcher ça peut marcher donc
ça n'a pas marché
oui et évoquerons une fois dit c'est
très bête ce que je dis de la wii ça
peut marcher pas marché c'est
rires ici c'est le preuve la preuve que
l'astrologie si vous voulez existe que
des choses n existe et bien maintenant
si mes copains lisent le truc ils lisent
et puis ils voient à assas et drôlerie
vrais gens il a fait beaucoup
d'accidents de voiture regarder les
taureaux et c'est évident a dit à l'ats
l'ept est la tante ursule elle va
beaucoup se flinguer parce qu'il ya du
poisson et si c'est pas ça le sens noble
de sens du livre cependant montrer tout
ça pour la preuve
mais les petites histoires et les
m'attendre à ma femme et moi ou elle et
moi je sais et bien ccc ça veut rien
dire du tout je vous dis que c'est autre
chose que karembeu luce un professionnel
de la drague dakar ont besoin très bonne
question
lui c'est un pro attention hein le mec
qui jette comme des roses au dessus de
chez vous et que l'hélicoptère
attention c'est pas
aa bien vous restez avec nous oui vous
avez raison
parce que maintenant c'est le car il est
très joli aussi c'est une vraie
newcomers on parle beaucoup d'elle en ce
moment elle s'appelle anna mouglalis
à
1 avant ce soir
voilà heureux de vous voir en vrai je
vais au cinéma dans le film de chabrol
qu'il faut dire qu anna mouglalis joue
dans le film de chabrol vous êtes très
bien très belle et on a eu tout de suite
envie de vous inviter en voyant le film
oui ça m'aurait servi à ça alors votre
agent jean françois gabart dites vous
chaque fois qu'elle entre dans mon
bureau j'ai l'impression de voir silvana
mangano bouchonne et silvana mangano riz
amer c'est normal la dégénération
pitbull toi disait faisait la maman de
tati insuline voilà la théorie aussi we
be votre voix ou si vous avez une voix
d'italiennes un peu cassé comme ça parce
que vous êtes grecque en fait évacuer
alors votre agent qui vous aiment bien
ça va c'est votre âge en même temps et
vous vend il dit anna est à des années
lumières des autres comédiens de sa
génération
allez bon arrive il faut le garder le
jean françois gabart
alors vous avez 22 ans j'ai fait trois
films terminal de francis girod qui a
pas été non plus faut le dire succès du
siècle non non c'est un péter succès du
sexe est restée la captive de chantal
akerman qui a eu plus de succès en tous
les cas qui étaient a bien apprécié par
là par la critique et maintenant merci
pour le chocolat donc de claude chabrol
avec isabelle huppert et jacques dutronc
madame ici il me connaît je lui ai
expliqué
oh non mika mais je vous connais
mademoiselle je vous ai vu à la galerie
c'est ça notre service derrière la vitre
qu'est ce qui vous amène excusez-moi de
m'introduire comme ça je sais que c'est
un peu ridicule mais il fallait
absolument que je vienne jeunes
apprendre que je suis peut-être votre
fille ma fille c'est que cette histoire
la passe est complètement folle non
écoutez moi je vous en supplie je suis
la petite fille de la clinique celle
qu'on vous a montré quand vous êtes
arrivé mais oui bien sûr je me souviens
de cette histoire mais on est pas ma
fille j'ai jamais eu deux filles c'est
une imbécile d'infirmières oui je sais
mais on aurait pu nous échanger on
aurait pu en a pas c'est votre père qui
m'a expliqué ce qui c'est passé un homme
remarquable devient il emma haché désolé
voilà merci pour le chocolat avec
isabelle huppert jacques bille tronc
rodolphe pauly et très bien rodolphe
pauly et anna mouglalis qui est notre
invité ce soir voilà alors je pense
qu'après on pose des questions adriana
pascal a pas vu l'extrait allait elle va
revenir où j'espère qu'elle va revenir
on va lui poser de trois questions
est-ce que tu avais d'ailleurs ah oui
encore surprime de micros on la voit la
regarde regarde regarde bien et en
attend c'est qu'elle a pu lever
mais adrien j'ai vu mais adriana torello
vert dans son contrat avec la croix
rouge
il ya marqué c'est clair elle n'a pas le
droit de se couvrir c'est dans l'intérêt
de la croix-rouge bon anna vous êtes
avec moi attendez vous savez pas vous
faire draguer par gunter sachs regarde
la télé vous regardez la télé on voit
bien on va bien et alors
alors ça c'est fait exprès bazire a
connu alors mettez bien extrait de merci
pour le chocolat de chabrol non joly ait
très bien mauvaise alors vous êtes en 3e
année de conservatoire avec mesguich
est ce que le regard des élèves a changé
sur vous pas plus que ça mais bon nous
vous trouve pas belle chose non non on
travaille pas beaucoup il ya un système
d'ateliers avec l'armée j'ai pas encore
fait ma rentrée avant que c'est toujours
pas fait votre rentrée c'est mieux
abattoir à ce chien non on travaille on
travaille mal août
le prochain spectacle c'est qu'en
février il vous a choisi comment chabrol
vous étiez beaucoup au départ
je les ai rencontrés en fait j'ai passé
un casting j'ai rencontré d'avoir sa
petite fille
enfin sa belle fille cécile maistre elle
m'a donné un texte à apprendre parcage
ensuite fait une séance d'essais avec
rodolphe pauly qui lui était déjà choisi
il a vu cette caisse est et puis on a
fait une séance de travail ensemble
et voilà c'est tout il vous a dit à
l'ats une tête de pianiste il m'a dit
que j'avais live musical hors et comment
les musicales olala tu es là et musicale
il faut le trouver ça quand même
non ça mais en fait vous saviez pas du
tout joué du piano vous êtes obligés
d'apprendre
c'était l'horreur j'ai appris à faire
son bon non c'était c'était bien moi ça
m'a permis de me concentrer vraiment
j'avais un travail est très rigoureux
afin de vous a plu vous aimez bien les
contraintes mais de quel signe pour voir
comme ça suite aux taureaux scorpions
comment ça marche
une période très très bien très très
bien que cela mais mais pas pour se
marier pour lever sur votre bien est
imparable
il veut qu'on ya trouvé un plan pour
draguer les hunters est une fille si
vous êtes trop ah bah moi je suis
scorpions va vous dire les statistiques
95% des des taureaux scorpions c'est un
amour fort bien et alors sur le tournage
comment s'est passé avec claude chabrol
sympa ouais très très sympathique il
bouffe beaucoup donc sur les tournages
nos talents merde quand on dit cela j'ai
bien dit mon vivant je verrai ton que ça
mais on avait très bien on se lave pas
trop tôt on se couche pas trop a pas de
tension pas de drame donc jamais confié
sa déjoue tous les fantasmes qu'on peut
se faire sur les ai tourné dans la
maison de david bowie
au lac léman au bord du lac léman qui
n'arrive pas à vendre vous connaissez
cette maison vous mais entre david bowie
n'arrive pas à la vendre parce qu'elle
ne donne pas sur le lac en fête
il en demande 16 millions je vous le dis
vous calez du pognon ça vous intéresse
si si hélène david là il peut vous dire
où la vie où il est mort là à celle
inverse
c'est la stratégie inverse j'ai voulu
leur ai dit tu verras on va faire des
économies on veut mettre beaucoup
d'argent de côté et un jour on ira en
vacances à madère et et gunther et 10 16
millions s'il y en a on a envie a pas de
problème ou tu vas toi il se dit la
semaine dernière j'avais ma fille c'est
incroyable j'étais bien j'ai votre
passion est venue comment c'est à dire
comment vous avez découvert que vous
aviez envie de faire ce métier j'ai
devrait aller au cinéma doit être aussi
mes parents m'ont mis on est assez
régulièrement et non c'est plutôt quand
j'ai commencé à aborder des problèmes
plus philosophique que ça m'a semblé
important de faire cette chose mais vous
savez attention ce une intello voilà si
elle a fait la fille cocagne est ou non
tu as ressenti si je veux dire non non
c'est vrai
1 c'est vrai un accès rien qu
intéressante du local vous avez voulu
faire mannequin puis vous savez vous
[Musique]
pourquoi vous n'arrivez pas à prendre
des poses oui c'est presque ça disons
que j'avais des idées préconçues
très présente et j'ai toujours eu peur
d'avoir l'air bête et je pensais que là
c'était vraiment le décor idéal
c'est une culture qu'on fait vite mais
moi j'ai rencontré des filles absolument
formidable quand j'ai fait ça qui
parlait trois quatre cinq langues
couramment ou alors qu'elle avait à
peine 20 tours mais moi j'y arriverai
pas j'y arriverai pas si vous voyez que
je m'ennuyais sur les côtés alors un
jour dont vous êtes venu à paris que
vous étiez à cuesmes à nantes qui est le
lola de jacques demy lé passage de la
pommeraie tout ça donc c'est une ville
déjà cinéaste avant même de commencer un
jour venait à paris et puis voilà puis
après bon vous avez fait des petits
boulots puis jusqu'au jour où
conservatoire avec mais ce bichon vous a
choisi pour faire ce film
ça s'est passé assez facilement
finalement ouais moi j'ai eu la chance
de faire des belles rencontres et vous
êtes toujours somnambule non ah bon j'ai
pas fais des crises depuis des décennies
même soleil c'était terrible a été c'est
vrai vous étiez somnambule elle et
sortez dans la rue la nuit non mais
c'est vrai ou pas c'est vrai c'était
problématique plus tôt pour mes parents
mais j'ai passé si souvent que ça ait un
jour vous allez rêver que votre frère
était enceinte et vêtue et sa
progéniture est un peu non si si j'ai
rêvé ça j'arrive et ça j'en ai beaucoup
parlé mais vous avez accès n'ont
toujours pas pourquoi penser qu'il vaut
mieux garder cette folie en vous et que
c'est ça qui vous permettra d'être une
grande actrice
non non j'ai beaucoup de curiosité par
rapport à la psychanalyse
je vais le faire mais je n'ai pas encore
eu l'occasion de vous dire que quelqu'un
je portais pas les hommes qui ronfle
jeudi alors oui si vous justement c'est
important si vous voulez pas lancer un
appel vous non ça va très bien sur le
plan amoureux parce que vous savez
qu'ici ça marche
incroyablement mais c'est vrai et non
mais c'est vrai il ya déjà quatre cinq
couples qui se sont formés ici grâce à
grâce à moi à commencer par la rousseau
car at il dit la russe au a rencontré
fabrice grâce à un appel que nous avons
lancés dans cette émission qui s'appelle
financer un appel non ça va oui oui ça
va et vous guy ce vote revient
ben oui ça va tous les doigts avant tout
le monde va bien on va pas refaire sa
vie
bon donc vous
les a pas de pas de problème vous avez
dit un truc de toute façon qui va en
calmer beaucoup vous avez dit les hommes
d'un soir ne m'intéresse pas histoire
sérieuse romantique avec beaucoup des
choses beaucoup de discussions ouais
c'est ça ben c'est bien c'est mais des
fois ça fait du bien aussi et elle a
fait hypokhâgne tu vois donc c'est une
autre culture bon anna on va on va mieux
vous connaître
on va faire une interview on n'a pas
bien fait pendant le jingle attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi tu fais ça j'ai confondu et a
confondu
ça fait trois semaines qui se prépare
pour cette émission
il a regardé le match le moment venu
après non mais je pense pas je pense que
le m j'ai deux fils guillaume si j'avais
été un arctique en tête au centre de
formation je me suis fait spécialement
nuit
aujourd'hui nous voulons rebelles vous
êtes concentré ses premiers souvenirs
ma première ivresse
ah bon cet accord c'était ça fait dix on
vous avait 22 ans
premier choc quand j'ai récité une
poésie dans ma classe cité en ce2 oui et
c'est à vous ça vous a plu vous ai dit
c'est ça que je veux faire 90 a vraiment
fait j'ai eu une part monstrueuse que
les mensonges ne sais pas et c'est pas
mal le mensonge en ça permet d'inventer
une réalité meilleur je crois que je
pratique et très tôt c'est une tranche
comme elles sont jetées lady avait fait
hypokhâgne ans n'a aucune chance
premier péché ya pas de pêcher ouais
pas me blesser rien et pc rien et ses
premières amours
il faut que je dise coin premier ramadan
vous n'êtes pas obligé de donner le nom
l'adresse ça vous dit il avait pas en
vacances et peut tout du petit j'imagine
non j'étais passé le titre que c'était
un garçon blond avec une queue de cheval
comme ça qu'ils bassin de mon collège
vous êtes sûr c'est un garçon premier
baiser sur un skateboard youtube
acrobates ce qu'il était tout petit
avant premier flirt poussé vers avait un
baiser avec la langue et tout ça mais
c'était la queue de cheval
non c'était le skateboard skatepark
première idole aznavour peut-être
première belle robe
j'avais une robe en lapin comme mes
amours je sais qui c'est moi c'est celui
de nantes à qui vous est venue à paris
non ouais c'est ça
et alors alors là ça devient chiant
première fois deux voies que vous avez
fait l'amour à deux avec un garçon ou
une fille première fois violente en
baisse et l humain merci
ah bon vous prêt à vous en sortir comme
ça je vais pas vous demander la première
fois à troyes parce qu'ici non pas ça
ici on est ici on est discret non je
demanderai pas la première fois trois
premières fois 4 jamais je n'ai pas
encore essayé vous avec 22 en même temps
première rupture première rupture
c'était à 18 on sait ce qu'est ronfler
non ils reflètent je peux vous demander
à quel âge avait fumé votre premier
pétard parce que ça c'est de la
provocation facile première ligne car
vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre
premier succès premier succès mais c'est
là c'est là si mauvaise pour ça que
c'est là tout le monde c'est clair
bientôt la première la première ligne
dans première n siècle je le connais
c'est terminal de giraud un seul et même
voix la première chose que vous faites
le matin au réveil je prends une douche
le matin
mouah ah je veux pas de douche jeu c'est
un truc que je fais c'est inconscient
j'ai vu ça dans un film crtv
ouais je
je passe la main j'ai un grand short
mondial de foot etc et je me passe la
main c'est inconscient après je vois mon
café vient bien tu te car aucune chance
aucune chance dans la mécanique ça parce
que je sais que plein de mecs mais c'est
inconscient c'est souvent on fait sa
dernière volonté si vous deviez mourir
là maintenant c'est important dit de
venir un nouveau profil devenir un an
avant c'est tout c'est pas plus chaud
que ça mais c'est très chaud douche
avant merci
et voilà maintenant j'ai dit au revoir à
patrick dupont au revoir patrick merci
donc le 7 novembre à l'espace pierre
cardin way l'air de paris oui c'est une
comédie musicale
oui tout à fait être un certain nombre
sur scène une dizaine sur scène on est
dix wydadis avec manon landowski à
anvers et à bientôt
je voulais dire anac elle est un enjeu
puisque on est tous des anges des
artistes
gunter sachs je le salue aussi la vérité
thorax ivoire
à
et maintenant j'accueille
ou alors à la mode
oh
alain minc bonsoir alors si j'ai mis ces
deux petites musiques avant votre
arrivée
c'est parce que vous êtes alors votre
votre curriculum vitae ou votre cv ténor
vous êtes chef d'entreprise sociologues
économistes et céistes mais surtout
consultant favori des grands patrons
tous les grands patrons cotisent dans
votre petite société votre petite
entreprise a trouvé un patron de pme
voilà sept patrons de pme est toujours
utile pour avoir vos conseils vous êtes
le consultant des grands patrons vous
êtes un stratège voir un entremetteur
ont dit vous êtes un marchand d'idées un
activiste du contact un boulimique de l'
influence
vous avez fait qu'une erreur en fait
dans votre vie c'est ça vous avez été en
95 et demander de voter balladur ça
c'est pas une n'est pas terrible non
c'est pas la meilleure idée mais à part
ça la meilleure idée
à part ça vous réussissez tout ce que
vous faire si votre éloge funèbre est
très sympa je le ferai si haut publié
chez grasset www.capitaltickets.ca sion
les mains
c'est bien la main un plaisir non ça me
fait très plaisir que quelqu'un comme
vous qui passe sa vie avec les jean
marie messier les arnault et pinault
vous jouiez le samedi soir aux petites
mains avec moi ça me touche
d'un seul coup je me dis que vous êtes
humains fidèlement bien alors le contenu
du bouquin c'est très simple c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est sur la
nouvelle économie
alors là la théorie dans la main que
c'est simple c'est de dire que la
mondialisation plus internet
c'est une révolution c'est un nouveau
cycle de croissance qui commence alors
dit que c'est comparable à à l'arrivée
du chemin de fer ou d'électricité
oui je crois qu'il ya eu trois étapes le
chemin de fer il ya un siècle à peu près
l'électricité il ya 50 ans et
l'électricité ça fait à la fois un
appareil de production qui fonctionne
mieux mais ça fait aussi la machine à
laver la machine à laver la vaisselle
leur est beau c'est à dire la vie ça
change la vie de chacun et internet et
le multimédia c'est la même chose ça
fait mieux fonctionner les gens les
entreprises de votre secteur
et ça change la vie de chacun alors
pourquoi vous dites le chemin de fer
électricité vous dit pas le téléphone ou
la télévision parce que c'est quand même
des inventions aussi clair vous
m'obligez à une explication compliqué vu
l'heure il faut d'un côté que ça
améliore l'efficacité du système de
production et de l'autre côté que ça
crée de nouveaux besoins à d'accord
alors le téléphone c'est un besoin
d'abord limitée qui n'en a induit pas
beaucoup d'autres avant internet et on
peut pas dire que ça a changé la vie des
usines
oui alors qu'internet on peut acheter
grâce à internet la vie des entreprises
on achète grâce à internet on est plus
efficace et puis quand vous mettez dans
votre propre budget boutabout ce que
vous mettez dans les bulles dans les
bouquets satellitaires ce que m était en
réalité dans le mobile ce que vous
mettez dans vos abonnements déjà
internet les jeux vidéos de vos enfants
et autres vous verrez que ça représente
une portion qui vous affolerait de votre
budget de vannes est donc toutes les
révolutions ne sont pas comparables en
fait
heureusement d'ailleurs ce sera un peu
ennuyeux alors ce que vous expliquez
suppose si compliqué que ça finalement
votre bouquin au début quand je les lui
je me suis dit ouh là là aux abris en
fait pas du tout vous expliquer qu'il y
avait un capitalisme managérial c'est à
dire c'est elle et les patrons qu'ils
possédaient et aujourd'hui on est passé
un capitaine patrimoniale c'est à dire
ses actionnaires qui sont rois oui avant
c'était les patrons qui dirigeait se
mettaient d'accord avec les syndicats
l'état regarder ça d'un oeil lointain
un veilhan et puis tout marchait et on
était complètement indifférent au sort
des propriétaires c'est à dire des
actionnaires aujourd'hui ceux qui
dirigent sont les actionnaires alors les
actionnaires c'est qui ce camp vous
placez votre vos économies en sicav vous
êtes un actionnaire les actionnaires
c'est vous c'est moi c'est nous tous qui
avons délégué notre pouvoir à une
quarantaine de milliers de types tous
profondément emmerdant mais qui ont un
pouvoir gigantesque et qui exige des
entreprises puisque aujourd'hui vers des
fonds de pension américains sur ceux qui
gèrent pour les touts les retraités
gestionnaire des fonds de pensions pas
seulement amérindiens d'amérique m en
face de lui aujourd'hui les maîtres du
monde à travers ses gestionnaires
finalement on travaille tous aujourd'hui
pour les pôles pour les petits vieux qui
sont en floride sur la chaise roulante
quoi abbey on travaille vous savez ces
gestionnaires gère l'argent des
retraités instituteur californie vos
propres économies celle de guy roux les
miennes à guy roux c'est l'économie les
a mis sous son matelas
ouais mais il a dû en laisser un petit
peu au crédit agricole
et alors ceci étant aujourd'hui on est
dans le triomphe et la dictature du
marché
la vie sociale est réduite à la
compétition c'est terrible d'ailleurs il
ya plus de doute beaucoup d'autres
espaces dans la vie professionnelle que
la compétition est ce qu'on est capable
d'atténuer les inégalités qui sont créés
par cette nouvelle économie
oui c'est ça le problème ça dépend que
de nous sait c'est la machine
capitaliste est une machine qui fait et
de l'efficacité et de l'inégalité alors
quand elle fonctionne à pleine vitesse
comme aujourd'hui elle fait beaucoup
d'efficacité et beaucoup d'idées mais il
faut aussi ne jamais oublier que 50% de
ce qui est produit repasse dans les
mains de l'état en principe pour réduire
les inégalités pas s'en prendre au
système cap de production c'est que nous
savons pas aider ceux qui en ont
vraiment besoin c'est vrai qu'on va vers
une société avec le retour de la
croissance où on aura le plein emploi
pour ceux qui peuvent et qui veulent
travailler on aura l'exclusion de
quelques millions de personnes et ça
c'est inacceptable et on aura à nouveau
l'immigration parce que les besoins de
main d'oeuvre ne seront pas autrement
c'est donc ce que vous dites est en fait
le problème c'est pas le nouveau capital
et de nouvelles économies c'est que les
politiques aujourd'hui redit
tribu mal les 50% du sang prélevé fait
les politiques c'est un ce sont des
miroirs
ils font ce que nous sommes prêts à
accepter louise écoute quand c'est pas
la peine de nous en prendre à eux
ouais nous n'avons pas accepté les
systèmes de solidarité qui éviterait qui
est dans une société hyper riches 5 à 6
millions d'exclus mais la machine
capitaliste le marché n'y sont pour rien
alors la gauche s'en sort par une
pirouette elle dit oui à l'économie de
marché non à la société de marché
combien tout comme toutes les pirouettes
ça durera pas très long mais c'est ça
c'est une forme de style ça ne peut pas
c'est une manière de descendre
l'escalier ans dans la rampe
ouais mais alors est-ce que vous à la
main que vous avouer pas également votre
reddition finalement vous dites une
société dominée par l'égalitarisme est
un leurre et au mot égalité vous
choisissez le mot équité et si on vous
écoute et la devise de la france devrait
être liberté et équité fraternité parce
que vous êtes très brillant vous
expliqué très simplement que la
différence entre l'égalité et l'équité
l'égalité c'est très simple c'est qu'on
rembourse chacun de nous quand on a une
défense
un accident de santé de la même manière
l'équité ça consiste à mieux aider ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin à rembourser à
100% un enfant d'exclus d'aubervilliers
pas nécessairement à 100%
un enfant de cadre dirigeant 4 ap un peu
froid sur les pentes de courchevel voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça comme quoi
rien n'est compliqué quand on sait
l'expliquer
alors vous dites pam qui a un niveau un
nouveau contrat social à inventer parce
que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
inégalités se creusent et donc est ce
que vous croyez pas possible oui c'est
le contrat social fait sur laquelle on a
vécu c'était de voir comment ont
distribué leurs revenus du travail et ça
fait cinquante ans que ça marche comme
ça aujourd'hui l'enrichissement provient
essentiellement des revenus du capital
le travail rapporte moins le travail du
capital en augmentation 4 5 fois moins
que le capital donc la seule vraie
question quand on raisonne en termes de
partage c'est comment partager une
partie des revenus du capital comme on a
appris à partager les revenus du travail
cette question qui paraît de bon sens et
qui devrait être celle de la gauche
parce que quand même payer pour assurer
le partage c'est vrai dire elle refuse
la pause et considère que le revenu du
travail ça doit être hyper partager mais
leurs revenus du capital il faut pas y
toucher
ce qui fait un bail parce que parce que
parce qu'elle le critique ceux revenus
du capital d'accor est le critique mais
vous pouvez aussi critiqué la loi de la
pesanteur ça ça fait jamais la gauche
n'a toujours pas mis ses revenus du
capital on l'entend à les partager
oui mais elle ne les admet pas et le
résultat c'est que l'inégalité en termes
de capital est gigantesque
donc au nom de la solidarité du travail
elle fabrique la plus grande inégalité
des revenus du capital
c'est un peu bizarrement ça il faudra
bien qu'elle change vous appelez ça les
dommages collatéraux c'est à dire tous
les to c'est un peu comme à la guerre de
bosnie du kosovo là c'est à dire que
finalement il ya eu pas mal de gens qui
restent sur le bord de la route quand
même savonné plus que pas mal jeudi
c'était il est absolument fou de penser
que même après quelques années de retour
de la croissance on va avoir cinq ou six
millions de personnes qui seront sur le
bord du chemin c'est insupportable et
absurde mais ça sera le cas en france
pas partout aux états unis vous savez
quand le taux de chômage est à 3% il ya
plus grand monde sur le bord du chemin
et pauvres mais il ya plus de gens qui
sont complètement exclus dont les gosses
donc une chance de trouver un travail
nous notre système malheureusement
fabrique cette sous société vous êtes un
libéral de gauche en fait oui mais c'est
un créneau assez peu occupé le seul que
je connaisse here
moi aussi il y avait strauss kahn et
mais j'espère que j'espère qu'il
reviendra dans le club très vite et il
ya les strauss kahn mais bon il est plus
et plus partie du club et voyez adriana
elle est l écoute tout mais c'est bien
voilà alors et linda traduit un peu oui
parce que c'est je suis prête
c'est bien belinda c'est bien bien alors
on va parler un peu de votre vie
l'avis d'alain minc alors vous êtes né
en 1949
vos parents étaient juifs polonais
communiste réfugié en france
votre père était le fondateur du journal
du pcf en yiddish
il a été pendant la guerre ftp maurice
qui était mouvement de résistance
notamment enfants de la république non
vous êtes tout à fait vous avez commencé
la communale vous allez finir les nanas
le lycée tout le système je suis un des
bénéficiaires de ce système qui est
formidable quand on peut vraiment en
bénéficier c'est ça mais on n'est pas
très nombreux en avoir près pleinement
profiter vous commencer l'école
communale
et puis vous terminez majeur de la promo
léon blum à l'ena quoi donc vous êtes
l'exemple même du parcours républicain
et un enfant la république un enfant de
la république
est ce que vous croyez qu aujourd'hui
cette idée d'abandonner l'égalitarisme
pour l'équité est ce que vous croyez que
ça rend possible d'autres alain minc
suis pas du tout d'accord
dès demain je participe à une fondation
qui donne des bourses à des gosses
quartiers en difficulté dans des lycées
de zones sensibles ont eu mention bien
ou très bien au bac pour les aider à
préparer les grandes écoles ce que leurs
parents ne pourraient pas leur offrir
et bien je vous assure que quand vous
voyez les promotions de ces boursiers
vous dites que en réalité le système
fonctionne encore le système fonctionne
toujours pour quelques centaines de
personnes d'accord le problème c'est
qu'il arrive à fonctionner pour des
milliers donc vous dites il y aura
encore des à la main il y aura ailleurs
encore des gens qui comme moi auront été
les heureux bénéficiaires et de la
république
les enfants de la république ne seront
pas des orphelins mais aujourd'hui vous
savez qu'on a coutume de diviser comme
ça entre d'un côté les républicains et
l'autre côté les démocrates êtes plus un
démocrate que républicain à au sens
idéologique ce qui brille bien sûr voix
la différence est que les événements est
un républicain par exemple
strauss kahn est un démocrate sur le
faire un républicain c'est quelqu'un qui
croit que la france peut échapper à la
loi du monde qu'on ne doit pas faire
l'europe et que l'étape tout un
démocrate c'est quelqu'un qui pense
qu'il faut faire l'europe que le marché
permet de créer des richesses mais qu'il
faut savoir par ailleurs à se planter
des politiques pour lutter contre les
inégalités leur en effet ce vêtement est
un républicain c'est le meilleur des
républiques
ce gain est un républicain ou moins
bonnes catégorique serait donc bien je
vous posais une question mais il faut
d'abord changer un petit peu la lumière
terrible alors la main qu est-ce que en
vous voyant être devenu le chantre du
capital
est ce que vous voyez pas que votre père
vous savez c'est un ancien communiste
ils ont fait aussi beaucoup de chemin
alors j'ai poursuivi le chemin qu'il
avait entamée si je puis dire on était
allé très loin parce que quand même lui
peut être communiste et avoir été déçu
par par le stalinisme il peut avoir été
des hommes par par budapest il peut
avoir été déçu par beaucoup de choses
comme ça
mais malgré tout il est quand même il a
un idéal au départ idéal communiste le
fait que son fils soit devenu le chantre
du nouveau capitalisme salon beige pas
dormi non mais vous voyez qu'en dit
libéral de gauche c'est assez utile
parce que j'espère que lui comprend
gauche et que les gens avec lesquels je
travaille comprennent libéral ouais très
bien on rallume
[Applaudissements]
alors à la mac comme vous êtes très
intelligent et très brillant
on va vous faire un quartier on va vous
faire l'interview nul c'est normal on ne
bouge pas on en est génial
[Musique]
c'est bien à anna ne bouge pas pendant
jingle vous non plus rihanna sait bien
les filles bien alors attention c'est
compliqué c'est l'inter du nul c'est la
main que vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère c'est nul j'avais versé nul
ouais mais je vous réponds les deux mon
général ça dépend des la nuit ma mère
qui est morte et là le jour mon père qui
est en vie voilà vous préférez hitler ou
staline staline quand même pourquoi
parce qu'il a tué plus de gens non non
pour une eau non pour une vraie règle la
différence si vous voulez c'est que le
communisme est un rêve dramatiquement
avorter le nazisme n'a jamais eu une
part de rêve commise le communisme vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est un idéal des
voiliers ouais le nazi de ses premières
[Applaudissements]
le mot le mot le plus con en amour c'est
merci encore
oui oui je trouve que lewis est plus
ambivalent
alors vous préféreriez mourir comme john
lennon qui a été abattu par un coup de
revolver comme otis redding qui est mort
dans une chute dans un accident d'avion
un crash comme janis joplin qui est
morte d'une overdose ou comme bones
scott le chanteur décide ici qu'est il
s'est étouffé dans son vomi à ça c'est
plus original comme mes bonnes scott non
la prochaine fois on verra mac avec des
petites cornes comme ici d'ici et puis
un short comme ambition si vous
préféreriez mourir tout de suite et
aller au paradis ou vivre encore
printemps et leur d'enfer en vivre
encore 30 ans et aller en enfer ça comme
je crois nir paradis ni allant gagner
les 35 heures
vous vous laver les cheveux tous les
combien comme vous plus trois fois par
semaine
pareil est ce que vous préférez un
président d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout pas d'élection du tout ah ouais
vous arrêtez de dénigrer le président
d'extrême droite et le suffrage
universel supprimera l'élection au coup
d'après ouais donc à tout prendre c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec hitler c'est
quand même ce qu'ils savent c'est vrai
qu'ils terre alors acquis
confieriez-vous plus facilement vos
enfants si vous disparaissez fier à
maxime gremetz noël mamère ou jean louis
debré euros avec maxime dereymez je suis
sûr qu'ils iraient à l'école et qu'ils
auraient de bonnes notes
si jamais vous retourner vers le
communisme quand même alors imagine est
une vue de l'esprit
vous rentrez chez vous vous trouvez
votre femme au lit avec rocco siffredi
quoi c'est un jeu l'esprit vous restez
en participant vous restez en boudant où
vous restez en vous pendant je médite
vous méritez je me dit vous partez pas à
jamais
aucune situation voyait même à votre
question je pars pas tout dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
amac www.capitaltickets.ca fr chez
grasset j'accueille maintenant yannick
bien vite je suis très heureux de vous
recevoir
bruce smith and parce que tu es là des
là dès la rentrée dès la rentrée j'ai
dit à catherine barma
alors ce tricoche indri kg dit il faut
absolument qu'on est yannick il adore ce
yannick voilà ça a pris un peu de temps
vous êtes là on est très content moi si
je compte alors j'ai lu dans un magazine
on vous demandait dans un magazine c'est
pas un peu ringard de passer chez
foucault drucker et vous répondiez au
cameroun dont vous êtes originaire tu es
reconnu quand il fait foucault et
drucker je suis désolé de voilà non mais
je suis fier d'être là aussi parce que
ça veut dire aussi que voilà que tout le
monde j'ai réussi à faire quelque chose
de bien je suis là parce que c'est une
émission qui est regardé et je suis
content d'être là je sais qu'il ya plein
de gens qui me qui vont me regarder
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont me qui vont être
jaloux d'ailleurs mais là déjà donné
l'exemple de sa tolérance génial bien
alors on a des fans au cameroun
justement en adjoumani qui est qui et
camerounais qui nous écrit qui nous
regardent sur tv5 toutes les semaines on
a subi mustapha lui les maliens résidant
en chine ces foules cette émission est
on à camara tibill etc et en mauritanie
voilà en fait cette émission le garder
dans le monde entier c'est sûr qu'au
cameroun on vous connaît ainsi sur vos
copains avant la voir alors on va
raconter un peu qui vous êtes parce que
moi je vous connais je vous adore ici je
pense que tout le monde est dans le même
cas signalés il ya des gens moi
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'ils connaissent pas la vague de
ziani alors didier premières chansons
influent
merci
alors
voilà il est parfait il a une façon
d'être
yannick moi je regarde beaucoup vos
clips sur mcm sur m6 vous avez une façon
d'être comme ça que j'avais bien aimé le
groupe quoi ça se voit tout de suite
vous avez le bon truc ça se voit tout de
suite
alors bon ça j'aime ta maïs et tu es
jeune tu amènes sur j'aime ton argent je
vous dis je vous ai fait hypokhâgne
voulait n'a donc j'ai obligé traduire en
fait en même temps moi j'essaie de
traduire
j'aime pas mal ça j'aime ton argent
vient alors cela c'était en 98 ça fait
quoi une centaine de millier de moins
d'exemplaires
voilà c'était un début déjà on avait
remarqué et puis alors cet été il ya eu
bah
et
ces deux millions d'exemplaires vendus
ça c'est le tube de l'été
alors c'est vrai que cette chanson au
départ c'était ça
charge pour la bonne heure
voilà mais avant c'était ça
[Musique]
la zéro qui la ville est fort season 6
mais avant il y avait encore ça
les
à
et voilà j'ai vu comment je fais regarde
là toi maman de carla et ouais à temps
il faut bien que je me donne un peu le
mec il a fait l'ena il conseille les
plus grands patrons on sait bien que
c'est impressionnant ce cas là vous m'en
voudrez pas bien alors maintenant vous
sortez ça
[Musique]
il
résister c'est intense il écoute ton
coeur son losc prend pas la tête et
pro-nazies lancé l'assaut sur le site a
envie de danser comme tu sais qu'ils
sont dans l'aval
on y va j'aimerais moi mon rêve dans la
vie c'est d'être comme lui voilà c'est
d'être capable de chanter
nous y reviendrons
n'était pas
pourquoi j'y vois là alors il est
vraiment bien
il vous plait c'est ce qu'a fils et moi
aussi
sur le plateau alors en fait c'est la
reprise de ça donne ça
[Musique]
pression dans les bars
moi
merci voilà alors on l'applaudît c'est
yannick alors la tis à l'instant sur
yannick comme vous allez bien dû servir
de monnaie j'espère que attention
attention adriana anna à la main guy
roux était temps
à
le
je suis content et voilà il en faut peu
moi finalement bien alors ça s'appelle
donc c'est ça qu'on aime c'est le cdc
chez sony epic
vous n'êtes pas quand même il faut dire
la vérité vous n'êtes pas très
revendicatif comme rappeur quand même
non parce que en fait avancé
appartenaient à un groupe qui s'appelait
maaf a tressé et puis un jour je suis
rendu compte que je me suis posé la
question excusera pour voilà avoir
l'image du bad boy comme l'ont souvent
les rappeurs ou s'il fallait que je sois
plus naturel et je me suis dit le mieux
c'est de ba d'être soi même et donc j'ai
voulu faire un album super intimiste et
parler que de moi de mes coups de mes
joies donc c'est pour ça que on parle je
parle beaucoup des filles aussi parce
que c'est un sujet que je puisse vous
voulez voilà je voulais parler de moi et
me présenter aux gens donc c'est pour ça
que l'album ressemble vraiment à 100%
mais il ya des revendications aussi mais
en même temps voilà tu vas pour prendre
la tête aux gens ce qu'ils écoutent mon
abonnement vous avez quand même eu un
enfant ça c'est pas dur mais l'enfance
ase d'année vous dit quand vous parlez
de votre enfance vous dites cité hlm de
chez hlm y est vous dit même si ça va
prendre le mauvais chemin sûr c'est pas
loin à un moment de nom c'est ça c'est
que c'est que voilà j'habite dans le 92
à bagneux c'est vrai que c'est assez
chaud c'est vraiment chaud j'ai grandi
j'ai grandi ben voilà dans le 92 et mais
non moi mes parents m'avaient inculquer
enfin moi un clic est une des valeurs
que j'essaie de respecter c'est pas tous
les jours facile et ça m'a empêché de
prendre le mauvais choix et puis la
musique elle est arrivée au lycée au
moment où il se cache dans l'impuissance
directement
ça m'a permis devant la musique il
arrivait au bon moment en fait c'est
parce que je voulais faire alors on est
de prendre le mauvais chemin et puis bon
j'ai eu le bac et je sais pas ce que
j'allais faire après la musique il
arrivé là donc je me suis dis bah je
vais chanter puis depuis ce jour là
c'est un marché puis bagneux vous dites
c'est quand même c'est dur quoi ces
extraits il ya beaucoup de divers de
coco verdejo et tout ça non mais il est
bon mais parce que voilà des fois je
vais me concentrer au dernier trimestre
et plus
et les parents qui sont derrière aussi
19 oct et le bac si tu veux chanter faut
avoir le bac
donc je me suis dis ouais vous
connaissez sans les parents son frère et
voilà vous avez eu le bac je me suis
concentrée au dernier trimestre
non c'est faux j'ai des copains qui sont
partis à fleury à bois d'arcy
malheureusement elle embrasse d'ailleurs
si mais je sais qu'ils regardent
l'émission et je le redis une grande
dédicaces et je pense à eux et puis
voilà voilà c'est ça si je me permets de
faire ça me sidère exemple alors à
l'école j'étais super timide avec les
filles
oui et maintenant ça va mieux à ses
énormes c'est la vérité on met à voilà
voilà donc maintenant sais pas ce qui se
passe a dit que je suis moins timide
c'est vrai en partie mais c'est vrai moi
c'est pareil on est tous comme ça c'est
vrai bout d'un moment bon geste - jimmy
ne vous êtes quand même pas comme vous
dites vous dis pas que vous avez
beaucoup de succès c'est vrai ça marche
énorme mais vous êtes quand même pas le
final le quoi le pin heures
oui c'est vrai que j'ai dit non c'est
vrai c'est que je passe à la télé très
souvent je regarde la demoiselle là qui
m'ont regardé tout à l'heure d'une
manière du cétacé toi tu sais que c'est
que c'est vrai que je passe à la télé à
la radio et tout mais j'essaie de pas
trop profité de cette arme redoutable
et c'est pour ça que j'ai dit dans ce
magazine que ce n'était pas au pin up ya
renoncé là il ne la cherchez je suis pas
le grand bonheur je suis à la recherche
de l'âme soeur
à mi-saison le plus c'est sa poussière
et pourtant alors donné mais c'est laval
y aller j'avais du mal parce que quand
vous montez sur scène les filles quand
même elle vous chauffe non non ça oui
c'est vrai que c'est arrivé récemment
d'ailleurs non mais ça fait vraiment
bizarre parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
vous montrent leurs seins ça arrive et
ça c'est vraiment ça ça moi ça va
mais c'est vrai qu'elle met les mains
dans le cantal ans ça ça ça arrive deux
fois et franchement et guy roux qui veut
se met au rap on se pense comme et with
you je pensais à la campagne électorale
du maire de tours oui aux
présidentielles les filles aussi
mais même dans les stades de foot qui on
voit des fois des côtés brésiliennes
mais également là pour le match du
brésil forme des jumelles pour les
tribunes tous les cas et ça je le dis à
toutes les filles qui regardent cette
émission vous n'êtes pas un garçon
facile et vous ne craquez pas tant qu'il
ya pas le petit quelque chose en plus
ouais je suis pas parfait papa à ce
point mais c'est vrai que oui un
supplice il faut qu'ils petit truc avec
vous même une fille qui est pas terrible
c'est pas de super canon mais si elle
n'a pas le petit truc en plus il faut
avoir quelque chose en c'est vrai mais
je m'en cache pas c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas toujours été avec défi super
mignonne mais avait quelque chose de
voir tandis 50 ans a fait un gros boudin
à la personne
je vais tout ça qui est marrant
bienvenus voilà mais bon j'essaye d'être
sur scène lui hommage à y aller mais
c'est trop fort alain faut aller voir
titoff non mais sérieux moi j'étais mort
de rire pendant tout le spectacle et
pourtant je suis un mec au départ plutôt
grave attendait jeudi en dehors de la
télé évidemment bon alors bon tout va
bien wayne on vient alors à temps pour
le jingle didier parce que je vais
d'abord prévenir monsieur yannick haye
on va faire une interview mensonge
mensonge bon donc tu ne réponds que des
mensonges bien entendu je décide
maintien c'est la bouche pendant le
signal
[Musique]
il
je suis heureux ce soir je suis heureux
personne ne bouge pas un dieu bon alors
interview mensonge c'est vrai qu'hier
soir vous êtes rentré avec deux copains
et quatre filles non c'est pas vrai je
rentrais avec deux homosexuels lire tous
ensemble c'est vrai que vous avez bu
trois litres de vodka marcacci c'est pas
énorme non j'aime qu'une le dit avant et
après qu'est ce qui s'est passé
elle fait partie en freestyle comme
d'hab c'est parti en freestyle comme
d'hab
et quand la con la file à la plus jeune
s'est trouvé mal c'était à cause de la
coke la tap les lakers ou non dans un
petit enfant tu dois m'en tire tu vas
pas dire la vérité
kalala quand même t'as pas honte quand
j'ai une fille qui qui qui dans cet état
là comme ça chez toi qu elle est bourrée
qu'elle a pris de la coke que tu crois
en dieu quand même temps tu mens dieu
toi moi non non tout ce qui vit là haut
ici l'huile à auxi une interview -
s'agit-il
il accepte mais oui le sait et c'est
tout bon tu es vachement peur de mourir
tout dans ces cas là dedans quand tu es
quand t'as fumé plein de paix tout ça tu
as peur de mourir non web grave tu te
rends compte qu'aujourd'hui ton vrai
dieu le seul dieu que tu honores
aujourd'hui c'est devenu l'argent c'est
l'argent entièrement j'aime la maille
il se dit aussi la voilà à l'émission
bravo
on passe maintenant d'autres aventures
on passe aux journalistes de france 2
qui a été otage à jo l'eau pendant 74
jours on passe à jean-jacques le gac
bonsoir ça va bah maintenant vous après
ce qui vous est arrivé je dois dire que
tout doit vous sembler sympa non ouais
parce que il y avait une bonne raison de
venir effectivement quand on est reçu
comme ça c'était sympa alors c'est ce
qu'on s'était dit avec roland madura il
ya un petit peu marre d'être là bas on
va faire quelque chose sans vraie raison
il ya thierry ardisson qui nous attend
lors la wii on est ravi de gourdes est
ravie de vous avoir surtout que le livre
on va en parler plus tôt plutôt
intéressant vous avez du mal elle
l'écrire c'est un peu dur mais le
résultat est bien bien alors
jean-jacques le garrec vous êtes prix
albert-londres 93 pour cinq jours à
sarajevo et vous couvrez depuis vingt
ans tous les conflits de la planète le
liban timor le tchad l'irak le
mozambique la bosnie le kosovo et joe lo
enfin vous êtes retrouvés à asolo alors
avant de rentrer dans votre récit dans
votre histoire
je trouve que ça pas été beaucoup fait à
l'époque expliqué un peu pourquoi ça se
passe comme ça là bas parce que
finalement les gens savent pas on leur
dit abou sayyaf savent pas très bien qui
c'est je crois qu'il faut dire qu'il ya
des rebelles dans le sud des philippines
dans ce qu'on appelle la porte de
derrière elle et les 400000 qui sont aux
philippines
il ya tout un tas de rebelles musulmans
qui veulent l'instauration d'un état
islamique voilà ça pas été clairement
dit non
oui c'est peut-être pas aussi clair que
ça et ça joue un petit peu sur tous les
tableaux il y à la fois effectivement
des rebelles qui revendique un état
islamique
il y avait effectivement une cette
partie des philippines qui depuis quatre
siècles n'a pas participé au
développement a toujours été un petit
peu
oppressés par les occupants dans
l'espagne a colonisé les films au long
de cette partie des 400 petit il a été
un peu laissé de côté ces saletés
laissées pour compte l'a en partie parce
que c'était des îles déjà peuplée
principalement de musulmans ouais donc
elles ont été laissées pour compte par
les espagnols pour ensuite les
américains maintenant par les philippins
donc il ya effectivement une oppression
qui dure depuis quatre siècles qui est
une tradition
et là dessus il y a énormément de
deux pirates il ya énormément de
d'entreprise crapuleuses quand même dans
la région et donc il ya des
professionnels du sport enlèvement et
donc ça ils savent très bien faire et
c'est à la fois des rebelles il ya aussi
tout un tas de désoeuvrés déshérités qui
sont attirés par le pognon des rançons
il ya des frais professionnels du
piratage des vrais pirates
et puis il ya une population qui est
facile ramener pour une cause politique
derrière pour rejoindre ceux là quand
ils ont un petit peu d'argent pour les
pour les payer quoi comme elle était le
cadet qu'ils ont c'est de retrouver
otage à jolo avec maryse burgot et
volant madd jura est aujourd'hui publié
un bouquin qui raconte votre histoire
ça s'appelle évasion 74 jours à jolo et
c'est chez xo notre ami bernard fixot
voilà alors au départ évasion c'était
plutôt les évasions de la pensée pour
vous non voilà c'est l'évasion finale
non non pas du tout peut-être l'évasion
finale dans le livre fait cinq lignes
pourraient ils vont ce livre a été
essentiellement écrit là bas que je suis
revenu avec le manuscrit et puis le 23
je suis rentrée le 21 septembre le 23 au
matin on m'avait mis en contact avec
bernard fixot j'ai eu le manuscrit je
dis voilà bon ça c'était écrit sur place
il m'a dit comment comment tu veux
appeler sam jeudi
je suis un peu gêné parce que quand je
l'écrivais c'était des moments où je me
libérer un petit peu de ce que je vivais
de ce que je vivais je voulais en me
disant tant que j'écris tant que je lis
je suis un homme libre voulait m'imposer
d'être libre et donc je lui dis j'ai
toujours pensé l'appeler évasion au
pluriel justement mais je vous dis
aujourd'hui ça fait un peu bidon pas
parce que le trivial comme on connaît la
fin musique après tout moi je ne
connaissais pas la fin quand je
l'écrivais donc il ya que les gens qui
vont découvrir le livre qui connaissent
la faim donc m'a dit non il faut garder
c'est très bien on va garder ça comme ça
à nous aussi on la connaît la fac
voilà donc ce qui est intéressant c'est
de connaître les autres évasions on n'a
qu'une que vous connaissez voilà oui il
ya plein de petites évasion c'est pour
ça qu'il ya un ace à l'évasion bien
alors dans la préface d'expliquer un peu
les conditions de votre départ vous
dites ok il a fait des progrès au cours
de la soirée avançait je pense je pense
qu'on va te lever environ après après
dominique faruggia de guy roux giroud
comme manager oui alors au départ donc
la préface vous raconter un peu les des
conditions de départ la bave outils
mission vous savez être dangereuse
mais vous dites bon vous l'avez dans la
peau c'est à dire que de toute façon
c'est votre vie ça c'est notre vie de
daleh où ça chauffe quoi oui c'est pas
c'est pas la première fois qu'on
comprend un coût comprend des coûts doit
plus y aller sur des missions vous
l'avez dit depuis 20 ans bon j'ai
couvert sarajevo manière assez assidu il
ya une balle qui m'a un peu brûlé les
cheveux
j'ai été au kosovo j'ai été arrêté par
les serbes pendant quelques heures on
est bon des guerres depuis 20 ans du
liban la guerre du golfe j'étais assez
proche de la frontière
donc ça fait un peu partie du métier ça
veut pas dire qu'on était brûlée ça veut
pas dire qu'on se dit que
rien ne peut nous arriver mais c'est
vrai que j'ai souvent pensé aux autres
otages deux touristes qui ont été pris
donc stéphane venne ligne sony avait une
ligne stéphanoise y est mari mort baisse
bon eux étaient en vacances il était
parti pour faire de la manger ils ont
été enlevés dans une île 20 heures de
bateau malaisie est donc là bon c'est
vraiment un enlèvement c'est vraiment
très très dur et puis pas du tout
préparés parce que tout à fait
inattendue moi dans ma vie de reporter
j'ai souvent été dans des situations à
risque et je me suis toujours dit que
peut-être un jour il m'arriverait
quelque chose de ce genre
je devais déjà partir au liban avec
philippe rochot quand il a été pris en
otage avec ses collègues et je n'étais
pas parti parce que je n'avais pas mon
visa mais j'avais vécu cette histoire de
manière très intense et je me suis
toujours mis un petit peu dans la peau
de ces gens qui avaient été pris essayez
d'imaginer comment réagir et donc j'ai
un peu toujours pensé c'est vrai que
quand je me suis retrouvé otages j'ai
refusé de me considérer comme une
victime
oui alors vous commencé le 14 juillet
2000 à tenir votre votre carnet donc
vous raconter votre vie alors folie
évidemment les jours il se passe rien
les gens il se passe des trucs très
intéressant les lectures par exemple
vous échapper beaucoup dans la lecture
oui on a eu la chance de recevoir
quelques livres au début ce sont les
l'autre groupe d'otages qui nous en ont
prêté puisqu'au début on avait vraiment
passé 50 au delà rien à voir à lire la
banque va se faire bien c'est quoi la
très vite ça manquait un petit peu quoi
on est beau construire un petit peu une
petite table avec des cailloux et un peu
de bois va pas très vite
ensuite on est de plus en plus de livres
et puis on avait à la fin on a une vraie
belle bibliothèque
ouais alors les lectures vite ça finit
par vous ankylosé l'esprit au dj honte
d'écrire ça parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas un moment vous êtes lisez
tellement que ça finit par vous prendre
la tête car là il ya des moments on en
avait quand même l'impression de vivre
quelque chose une espèce d'ascèse quoi
manger peu
la vie était quand même fait de peu de
chose et donc c'est une manière aussi de
se dire bon bah c'est peut-être une
manière de purifier l'esprit et puis
d'aller un petit peu fond de soi même de
se laisser de se laisser vivre de se
laisser prendre par cette ascèse qui
permettait peut-être de se laver
l'esprit il en avait envie
j'avais envie en tout cas c'est
peut-être plus personnel de me laver
l'esprit et puis finalement je prenais
un bouquin j'étais pris par le bouquin
est bon mais une fois que j'étais pris
par le bouquin effectivement je salue
terreau kg s'est arrêtée complètement
libre au bond et donc un moment je veux
aussi est-ce que je suis pas en train de
louper quelque chose est-ce que je ne
suis pas en train de louper un moment où
je pouvais effectivement faire le vide
est allé très loin est bon les bouquins
m'encombrer mais bon il était bon les
bouquins donc j'étais encombré
volontiers oui
jlc moma lorsqu'elle plus dangereux
j'imagine que c'est ces mômes qui est
qui qui tirent en l'air comme ça qu'ils
déchargent leurs armes
vous dites c'est leur bêtise qui
finalement est la plus dangereuse quoi
c'est à dire qu'on peut mourir d'une
balle perdue tirée par un monde qui sait
pas ce qu'il fait quand il est seul
accident qui a eu c'est effectivement
souvent des balles perdues il jouait
avec leurs pétards de temps en temps et
de temps en temps il les balles qui sont
parties où il fallait pas sinon le jeu
principal c'était d'essayer de décrocher
des noix de coco bonds voir ça ça va
c'est beaucoup plus haut que nous alors
bon les trophées c'était les noix de
coco donc temps que c'était les noix de
coco ça allait mais de temps en temps
bon aussi commencé à vouloir simplement
faire des rythmes partie reposé là un
bon s'est il ya eu des accidents dans
l'autre groupe dont des balles qui sont
partis des mômes qui se sont blessés
entre eux simplement parce que
non ils ont une maîtrise assez lisse et
quand même désormais on va regarder un
petit peu l'ambiance la bachelot marc
simon
[Musique]
quelle aventure
alors voilà puis alors il ya plein de
petits détails comme ça que j'ai noté
mais en a plein d'autres et un jour un
mac effet des étudiants en arabie
saoudite qui vient vous voir comme celle
qui vous dit vous êtes est resté un an
ici quoi il ya des jours évidemment on
se prend des trucs comme ça dans la dans
la gueule puis à cette inquiétude
permanente
cette espèce de 2,2 de lourdeur comme ça
de deux il ya deux choses
il ya toujours cette envie cette idée
que la libération va va être très proche
peut arriver mais ça bloque c'est comme
quand vous cherchez un mot vous faites
des mots croisés vous cherchez un mot il
est là mais ça veut pas venir et ses
espèces de paralysie de l'esprit qui est
permanente parce qu'on a toujours
l'impression que ça va arriver c'est pas
là également cette idée que ça peut
foirer à chaque instant d'ailleurs c'est
un peu foiré sur la fin et que donc il
ya quand même toujours la mort qui
domine et qui est prête à l'heure on est
à la fois en face d'une libération
possible immédiate comme ça tout instant
mais ça veut pas venir donc on a cette
impatience est pas une impatience ma
faim l'esprit est un peu paralysés par
rapport à ce truc qui veut pas que la
télé puis la mort qui effectivement
peuvent surgir au coin de la rue de la
même manière alors vous dites alors
c'est en vain qu'on verse semaine tu es
là et toujours les deux derniers jours
tu t'éclates c'est exactement pareil je
te signal social éclaté à la fin alors
vous dites je pense est superstitieuse
man que je serai libéré le lendemain du
jour où j'aurais complètement fini ce
carnet mais c'est incroyable c'est
arrivé ça ce soir et ce soir oui montré
ce soir on est vraiment dans le ce soir
on est vraiment dans un truc
voilà voilà le carnet je vais me la
passe que dans les moments les pires les
moments les plus durs on se disait bon
voila il va peut-être falloir qu'on
decani vite fait parce que temps en
temps les avions est un peu proche donc
qui aurait pu le temps de prendre un sac
ou quoi que ce soit moi j'avais commencé
à l'est mais un peu car n'est donc je
m'étais dit celui-là je voudrais le
ramener et donc je me suis dit qu'on
écrivait son carnet il se disait un jour
une carie sera fini je serai libéré et à
la fin il écrit de plus en plus petit
des voiles alors bon le carnet été créé
à peu près correctement
et puis bon à la fin je triche un petit
peu parce que voilà et l'art la fin
c'est très serré lâchez pas si vous
arrivez à le voir mais à la fin c'est
très très serré ses cris de plus en plus
petits mais finalement les derniers mots
sont écrits ici dans le bureau du
général quand je suis libéré et là je
dis je vais faire une conclusion sur ce
support que je fais ici sur le support
dans l'avion du président voilà alors
moi c'était ma super six
il y avait les évangélistes et
l'incroyable cette histoire de prier
toute la journée pensant que leur prix
allaient libérer moi j'ai annoncé mon
carnet qui va me libérer
ça marchait et ça a marché alors bon y'a
plein plein de choses dans votre livre
on voit très bien un moment où se mettre
en place
les négociateurs libyen alors vous dites
c'est la grande mascarade se met en
place et refi annonce minute par minute
le scénario et vous dites l'étape
clownesque de tripoli non je bien être
otage d'accord mais pas bouffon et amant
vous perdez vous perdez espoirs vous dit
peut-être que ses notes
enfin qu'on vient de voir verront jamais
le jour et pour iront dans mon sens
c'est à dire qu'évidemment il est des
moments d'abattement comme et alors vous
partez donc un moment parce que la base
est attaqué et voilà
j'aimerais super
je me suis fait la belle
je me suis fait et voilà bravo merci
c'est génial génial en plus d'être cool
êtes là vous raconte les salles abbaoui
sur la salle saint pierre desgraupes
avait dit le manque de chance c'est une
faute professionnelle
ouais donc vous êtes dans la ligne des
groupes c'est bien sur france 2 oui en
plus de vous partez quand à jérusalem on
voit tant que ça se calme est peut-être
ailleurs
vient alors jean-jacques le garrec comme
celui des hauts et des bas on va vous
faire c'est normal une interview à peine
d'amendé ding
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien ce que vous préférez à peine
d'annoncer le plus le moins c'est facile
que vous préférez dans le métier de
grand reporter quand on fait ce métier
c'est qu'on est curieux qu'on aime la
découverte et même les gens donc voila
moi j'aime les rencontres et j'aime les
voyages j'aime découvrir ce que vous
détestez dans le métier de grand
reporter
parce que je déteste c'est quand tu peux
pas y aller quand effectivement ce qui
se passe des choses et qu'on peut pas y
aller cela n'a pas les moyens soient que
c'est interdit alors ça j'aime pas du
tout d'accord
le reportage de vous vous préférez ces
reportages que j'ai fait avec dominique
derda et vendre les murs au cambodge
passé un mois dans la nuque est en train
de se rouvrir après le retour de
sihanouk et j'ai passé un mois 9 est un
magazine pour le dernier numéro de
résistance ou fax et par émission à la
mer voilà on va faire un magazine d'une
heure d'un moment de vie est au magazine
fournisseurs d'accès alors ça c'était
celui que vous préférez le reportage de
vous vous détester ce que vous avez pas
à ce que j'aime pas du tout c'est celui
que j'ai pas fait à jo mais c'est parce
que je n'ai pas fait ce que vous
préférez en vous une chose que j'aime
bien moi c'est que j'arrive pas à me
sentir victime j'ai un énorme complexe
de nom persécution et c'est vrai ça
embête énormément de monde
oui c'est vrai on est là et moi ça me
plaît bien mais ce que vous détestez en
vo il ya un truc qu'on me reproche
souvent oui c'est que quand j'y pense
pas j'oublie de souris alors on produit
un risque mais c'est pas vrai à
l'intérieur c'est vrai mais bon côté le
garrec peut-être le plus grand moment de
votre vie
c'est la naissance de mon fils je crois
que c'est assez banal et le nez c'était
un beau le pire moment c'est la mort de
mon père quand j'avais 11 ans ce qui
fait le plus rire dans la vie à ce soir
c'est vous ce qui me fout vous ferez le
mois d'août est le mois à rire à ce
qu'il fait pas rigoler c'est la
circulation à paris ce dédale geollot
voilà là bas au moins en marche on est
tranquille mais en plus on peut essayer
de vous évader de la circulation à paris
ça marche pas oui la plus belle nuit de
votre vie ben là c'est gentil mais enfin
bon je viens d'en parler quoi quand même
c'est une forme de renaissance est donc
effectivement là une vraie renaissance
qui me permet bas qui m'a permis de
retrouver les gens que j'aime de
retrouver ma compagne de retrouver tout
le monde lui c'est votre évasion
évidemment jolo est commun mais la plus
moche la plus moche ça aurait été
l'évasion s'il avait loupé quoi
là
tout le monde en parle c'est normal il a
eu le prix goncourt pourtant ça faisait
30 ans qu'on est pas une nouvelle de lui
ou elle si jean jacques schuhl
ma
à voir si adriana côté demande comment
ça va c'est là jean jacques
oui ça va vous en avez ras le bol là non
ça fait une semaine qu'on vous traîne de
plateaux de télévision en place ou non
sa main ça m'amuse plus tôt je vais pas
me parler de ça dans ce que j'écrivais
dans rose poussière puis d'encore
maintenant il ya seulement deux
photographes de j'aime bien les les
petites mythologies les médias ça me
plaît assez les journaux voilà je suis
dedans bien donc ça va ouais non je suis
bien le panda corps dont je m'amuse
c'est comme un peu comme un jardin
d'enfants ça ouais c'est ça qu'il faut
en profiter c'est comme miss france un
concours sûr que maintenant un nom très
bien où il va coûter alors j'ai obtenu
concours lundi dernier pour un livre
intitulé ingrid caven qui est chez
gallimard
voilà
donc au meilleur moment mais on y arrive
oui leur faire bien alors c'est vrai que
le goncourt en 98 il avait raté
houellebecq il avait les particules
élémentaires
il avait récompensé paul constans pour
qui ça fait confidence pour confidence
donc ils ont eu un peu honte sûrement et
l'année dernière déjà il avait essayé de
se racheter en couronnant echenoz zaveck
je m'en vais et cette année ils sont
complètement racheter alors y'a plus
rien à dire le goncourt est devenu à
nouveau tout à fait fréquentable le jury
le jury du goncourt puisqu'ils ont
couronné votre livre jean jacques schuhl
alors c'est votre troisième roman donc
et rose poussière en 72 qui est un livre
culte là c'est comme robert wyatt dans
le rock'n'roll certain temps dit et
quand on disait parce que maintenant
c'est fini
et quand on dit the rose poussière a
révélé mais qui connaissent et rose
poussière c'était des bonbons maintenant
bon évidemment tout le monde le sait
puisque c'est le prix goncourt mais
maintenant c'est fini c'est fini tant
pis et voilà on a été rejoint par
d'autres alors en 76 8 et l'ex numéro 1
donc voilà ça fait pas grand chose ça
fait soixante douze rose poussière 76 t
l'ex numéro un serait donc 25 ans vous
aviez pas à publier et on sait pas grand
chose de vous finalement vous êtes resté
très très secret on sait que vous êtes
de marseille d'une famille de
commerçants juifs de marseille ce tout
ce qu'on sait alors vous dites vous-même
d'ailleurs pas de mariage pas d'enfant
presque pas de métier rien zéro voix
c'est votre bio oui je vais dire guitare
si non alors souvent même face les
angles non non non non même pas noms du
tennis
ah ouais je faisais pas prêt alors ça
fait 25 ans qu'on vous a pas entendu
donc on n'a pas lu quelque chose de vous
évidemment on vous connaît on sait que
vous êtes là mais bon est-ce que c'est
pourquoi ses 25 ans de silence de plus
je sais pas je n'avais pas de je suis
pas un écrivain introspectif d'être
stimulés par départ les choses
extérieures et puis gelé
j'ai trouvé pas loger
j'ai pas j'ai pas écrit jusqu'à ce que
je rencontre cette femme ce modèle je
décidais de commise et kafka mettre
certaines choses à l'abri de la mort et
donc raconter les choses qui me
paraissait intéressante sur elle sur les
gens qui l'ont entouré fassbender c1 et
d'autre alors vous êtes quelqu'un de
façon qu'ils prenaient du temps parce
que ingrid caven la vraie parce qu'après
on va voir il ya une grille de cave est
née puis celle du roman mais ingrid
caven dit avec jean jacques se sont tous
prend du temps et c'est vrai que vous
êtes quelqu'un de parce que ce bouquin
rien écrit depuis 76 et ce bouquin vous
avez retardé l'impression qu'un mec mais
25 ans pour feuilleter des livres et
vous avez retardé l'impression je suis
très intense monarchy fait l'arraché je
suis très choqué très indécis d'ailleurs
le dernier signe que je suis allé au
inextremis amené à la fabrication qu'on
a qu'on a faxé à aux imprimeurs qui se
trouve en mayenne où je ne sais où je me
suis précipitée c'était un point
d'interrogation qui manquait mais voilà
les points où il entend fait trois
livres en 50 ans c'est un pas un samatan
alors vous avez mis votre génie dans
votre vie comme dit oscar wilde c'est un
génie c'est à grand bruit un peu
d'amusement et de talent mais pas de
jénine
ouais quand le livre est consacrée
ingrid caven elle sort un disque on va
faire la promo du brie de karen on va en
profiter sur indices qui s'appelle
chamberland 550 oui et puis
fait un concert au théâtre de l'odéon
voilà 29 novembre il ya là une grille de
caven du du du disque la chanteuse qu'on
connaît et puis à celle un peu plus
mythologique du livre vous dites en
parlant de ça d'ailleurs
c'est comme un conte de grimm il était
une fois une lettre qu'avait moi oui
ça commence dans la neige titi en
fourrure qui mélange de ferries
d'horreur puisque valve a chanté devant
les officiellement la hausse la baltique
où son père est une garnison et
soit photo d'adolphe hitler ça commence
comme ça guérit on le livre de l'adf de
la feri l'horreur n'est jamais loin
la première scène c'est ça c'est noël 43
ingrid caven à 5 ans elle chante je
trouve une art devant les dignitaires
nazis et alors bon toute la première
partie vous parlez des années 70
fassbender warhol jean pierre rassam
vous n'avez pas connu jean pierre rassam
jean pierre rassam c'était un producteur
un sens et c'est lui qui après kaka a
porté la gaumont à nicolas seydoux et
c'est un type délirant assalam c'est à
dire il avait toujours des trous ici
parce qu'ils avaient des shoots et
bolides ravissante actrice autour de
maman me relever oui oui oui beaucoup
d'autres et
et puis c'était quelqu'un qui jeudi
avait l'attrait du la fascination pour
le gouffre il était prêt à tout
engloutir son argent et tout pour pour
dévoiler la vérité pour s'amuser pour
provoquer provoque vitesse c'était ça de
plus ou moins ça semble être sa devise
est un comme on n'en fait plus quoi
penser que c'est comment il a été évincé
par toscan du plantier qui est l'
inverse de jean pierre roth samm ou et
comme bas aujourd'hui cinéma qui a
changé aussi
la preuve on va vous parler de races à
mon personnage hors du commun vous
parlez de yves saint laurent campoy en
train de découper drogue
surig et de calais mais ce culte
carrément larouillies avesnes il mène
avec des canards à la fête de l'eau de
la falaise
je sais pas qui ça parle pas du tout les
trucs que nous on a vécu mes lauriers
les années 70 puis après il ya autre
chose c'est-à-dire que ça c'est là la
première période ce que jean françois
bizot appelé les années blanches et puis
après il ya la deuxième partie c'est une
dispute entre entre caven et charles le
narrateur qu'elle n'est pas vous mais
qu'un peu vous et sa valse pas mal ça va
valser pas mal dans l'appartement tout
se casse
c'est une scène un peu burlesque où il
est question à la fois de sexe de
religion et de
le femme de
de toute minorité tout ça sur le mode
que j'ai essayé de rendre burlesque
comme baudelaire disait traiter les
sujets tragique avec frivolité l inverse
et se termine d'ailleurs par une scène
un peu on apprend la mort le narrateur
rentrer il apprend la mort de fassbinder
et la troisième partie on trouve enfin
vous charles trouve près du lit de
fassbinder le synopsis d'un film qui est
un peu le synopsis du bouquin donc la
boucle se boucle
exactement c'est s'éteint c'est comme
une feuille qui lui a échappé
l'alerté au moment de la mort sur lequel
il a écrit son petit c'est à dire des
choses qu'il a écrite c'est sur une auto
au verso d'un du script de lits marlène
sert d'un gros un film à gros budget il
a écrit là en 18 points les stations
étape de la femme qu'il avait seulement
aimé qu'ils étaient une quinzaine
et donc
qu'il a écrit à la main c'est là dessus
ça s'accepte ça passe entre ça arrive à
notre caverne qui le transmet à charles
mais c'est comme un défi pour écrire
lui-même à ce moment là plus ou moins en
tous les cas c'est gonflé de la part des
goncourt d'avoir couronné votre livre
parce que baroque
ils sont pas bons je revendique la
notion de baroque surtout que je trouve
ça bien
je veux dire baroque se dire là c'est
pas la surcharge pour moi c'est le la
possibilité de mélanger plusieurs styles
comme dans comme dans tous les domaines
y compris dans le sport dans le tennis
je pense que mcenroe était un joueur
baroque et dont je parle de wind on
jeudi dans tous les domaines ça a
disposé tout ça c'est le son de maroc
est-ce que je savoir finalement c'est
bon vous écrivez et rose poussière début
des années 70 se succéder steve vous
avez vendu 3001 près de 1800 et puis bon
les gens savaient mais enfin c'était pas
le gros succès thé l'ex numéro 1 c'était
encore moins vendues donc voila et puis
trente ans après on vous donne le
goncourt et tout le monde dit c'est un
bon concours c'est pas comme paule
constant c'est un bon goncourt quel
effet ça fait est ce que vous vous dites
ça y est mon immense génie temps phare
connu pas du tout c'est un coup
d'éclairage et
un ampli porté sur un état d'esprit pas
tellement sur moi mais sur un état
d'esprit que j'ai essayé de faire passer
dans ce livre qui est un peu disparu cet
esprit baroque dont je parlais aussi que
si j'inclus en voyant ce qu'il ya et
dans la littérature dans le sport tout
ce que vous voudrez qui a un peu disparu
au profit du réalisme c'est un gros coup
d'ampli là-dessus mais je continue à
revendiquer à tous et très bien les
trucs under ground des trucs pour 2800
je pense qu'il faut faire un effet aussi
dans l'ombre n'y a pas de hiérarchie
un livre à 2500 et un livre à 250 mines
c'est pas forcément on cherche pas de
calais le mieux je veux dire je suis
très content a part ca de se voir le
second ampli que j'ai merci jean jacques
alors maintenant mesdames et messieurs
nous arrivons au climax de cette
émission le blind test mais avant non
didier
avant je voudrais lire quelques petits
mails concernant michael alors les gens
demandent s'il avait du rouge à lèvres
la semaine dernière non je pense pas il
ya un mec qui dit j'suis pas les chutes
chez rim et michael bush par le jingle
et un autre qui dit un truc énorme il
dit est ce vraiment le même michael qui
est venu toutes les semaines mais oui
c'est lui simplement été pas look est
pareil tu peux y aller vivier
[Musique]
vient alors le principe du blind test
kruger où il me disait qu'il y parlait
de garrincha dans son livre ouais je lui
répondais je ne les ai pas encore lu on
me l'a pas encore au fait diront il vaut
mieux lui en faire cadeau parce qu'elle
n'a cette fois pas de toute façon dont
je préfère lui donnait bien je vais lui
demander de me le dédicacer qu'adriana
vous avez froid savalas ans le blind t
ag stick le principe jean jacques guy
n'en faut vous concentrer après dites
pas que je vous ai pas expliquer un donc
le blind test 1 c'est un spécial grandes
villes du monde donc didier paass une
musique vous devez me donnait
l'interprète
si vous ne trouvez pas l'interprète
cortier michael peuvent répondre mais
ils n'ont pas le droit de répondre le
public encore moins ils n'ont pas le
droit de répondre tant que vous n'avez
pas trouvé
donc c'est les grandes villes du monde
c'est clair et après il ya un petit duel
entre quartiers michael mais ça c'est
pour le bien
donc grandes villes du monde première
chanson didier
[Musique]
oui
ainsi un message et le chai
l'échauffement claude françois que
chaque chanson numéro 2 didier
georges
le débat demandez leur
bien avant poids pour titeuf un point
pour jean jacques schuhl à côté face
alors quoi n'a pas de chance moi bon
allez au boulot ardisson chanson numéro
l'interface du bureau bureau
sauvé la vie
on est plutôt bon avec un niveau des
plus tôt pour faire style de trouver les
villes
[Musique]
non
shitov de réclamations s'il avait fait
signer mais là c'était la lisa mais on
n'a pas encore entendu quand il a dit
que ça a joué à sa geôle haut avec un
atout les kalachnikovs saemss elle aussi
chanson numéro 5
l'interprète
button au string
inconnu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la caisse
hier jouer moi
e
[Musique]
si ça continue quand même pu louer des
hollywood bananas non c'est pas cette
version non michael le public vient
manhattan transfer bravo mademoiselle
dans tous les cas didier l'interprète
sa dignité
[Musique]
bravo
bravo maudet
la ville s'est bangkok numéro 7
we want
pas plus
c'est triste
elle est bien lauren bacall chanson
numéro 8 10 tonnes
droit
honorable etienne daho à numéro 9
vous allez faire - les marioles tétouan
alors vous vous répondez pas les invités
d'abord
[Musique]
arrêt titoff francs
la guitare quelques lueurs d'aero
shi étrange fille aux cheveux d'or
dans ma mémoire
j'aime les invités savent pas
fromelles
enfin pour tous à 60
corti très bien nicolas peyrac et
entendu ce far away from hell est
chanson numéro 10 didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les années 50
les années 50 avant cinq ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est antoine un regard alors là
franchement les mecs charles trenet au
revoir paris révélation didier
[Musique]
charest aïe aïe faut vous y mettre
allez on n'avait rien d'évident chanson
numéro 11
l'interprète
[Musique]
il a trouvé toi
ah oui mais attend
[Musique]
hitachi et dans le dessin des taxis non
stop du mélange de guizeh mais bon un
port cartier bien alors lance titoff 3
donc pour le moment c'est titeuf qui
gagne maintenant le super banco est
ouvert à tout le monde c'est à dire même
à corti même amical au public
le super banco je veux l'interprète du
super banco didier
[Musique]
c'est le noir dez c'est tout lui va
qui sait pas vraiment micro de david
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai dit navi quoi je suis un gros
besoins des parents c'était moi aussi
pardon n'est pas dynamique c'est pas bon
il a dit david bory je suis désolé
parfait aux mineurs bon bah voilà
non
merci adriana karembeu et on va tous
apprendre le geste qui sauve à la croix
rouge à la mac ww capitalisme point fr
chez grasset notre ami gunter sachs
le dossier de l'astrologie chez michel
lafon jean jacques le gac évasion chez
xo yann me fais ce qu'il te plaît chez
peak anna mouglalis merci pour le
chocolat de chabrol
patrick dupond étoiles et les airs de
paris dont kate nash cardin à partir du
7 novembre
jean-jacques soul le prix goncourt pour
idée de karen voilà chez gallimard
l'infini sollers diront entraîneur de ma
vie écrit par eugène saccomano des sages
mais ce n'est
equinox au palais des glaces jusqu'au 30
décembre
merci
une bonne salle
là
m
[Musique]
j'ai plein d'amis
m
[Musique]
il
on a créé
mais même si moi
jusqu'où
il
[Musique]
tél
non
[Musique]
vers le haut